thank you Joe Biden's disinformation
board is done it has been suspended and
Nina jankowicz the director of this
program has resigned in shame the
amazing thing is the news breaks through
Taylor Lorenz who writes an opinion
piece about it blaming who was it Jack
passovic and the post-millennial yeah
would it be your fault yeah it's
entirely our fault we take the credit
y'all all right we got a bunch of other
stories though uh half of uh Joe Biden's
followers are fake according to an audit
Elon Musk is confirming yes in fact he
will be voting Republican Twitter says
they're going to force him to buy
Twitter and they say they axio says they
turn they turn the table on him and I'm
like they didn't want to sell to him in
the first place and now they're
demanding it I think Elon has won this
one we've got a couple other interesting
stories there was a news that broke of a
female skateboarder who lost she won
second place but she she was knocked
down because of a male athlete a trans
woman
who competed and she made a post about
an Instagram that's going viral at the
same so we'll discuss that too uh
skateboarding of course is near and dear
to my heart I know a lot about this and
a lot about the physics involved which
matters when it comes to the difference
between differences between males and
females but then we also have the U.S
soccer the men and women are going to
share the World Cup prizes yeah that
doesn't seem reasonable at all that
seems weird yeah but uh we'll talk about
it and obviously Libby's here here I am
who are you here I'm Libby Emmons I'm
the editor-in-chief with the
post-millennial glad to be here
right on we got shim sham Sheamus I'm
Seamus Coughlin I create cartoons at
Freedom Tunes if you guys want to check
that out uh go over there we're going to
be releasing a new cartoon tomorrow also
if you want to go to freedomtunes.com
put your email address in the little box
we will email you when we launch on May
30th we're also gonna have a
subscription service where you'll get
extra cartoons for five bucks a month
we got a lot he's back awesome what's up
everybody I am Milad I'm an on the
ground reporter for timcast thanks for
having me and honorary Ian today
honorary Ian honorary not really Ian but
you know close enough he's our knockoff
Ian for the evening I'm also here
pushing buttons in the corner as I do
every evening Great Value Ian yes before
we get started my friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can
pick up your ageless multi-collagen if
you've ever wondered why I look so young
it's because I eat this stuff
collagen is what you need for your skin
your joints your hair your nails I was
uh I was actually skating the other day
and I ate it you know there's an sh
that's supposed to go before that last
one but I think I almost broke my arm
too but I got strong bones so uh so I'm
good head over to strongerbones in
life.com you'll get a 60 day money back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen inside in its ideal forms five
key types of collagen you need from four
different sources for every order today
BioTrust will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor to their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals two hungry kids please out
bio trust hit their goal of six million
meals this year it is non-GMO and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and RBS team
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements
there's no clumping unlike other
supplements you'll get free shipping
with every order free VIP live health
and fitness coaching from BioTrust team
of expert nutrition and health coaches
for life with every order and their free
new e-report the 14 foods for amazing
skin with every order and uh no joke I I
slammed on my arm really bad and I think
I should have broken it but uh strong
bones so go to strongerbones in life.com
pick that up shout out bio trust thanks
for sponsoring the show also don't
forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member as a member you'll get
access to our exclusive members only
show coming up at 11 PM tonight you will
be supporting our journalists and our
writers our opinion writers and
columnists and you're supporting the
companies that we utilize in terms of
infrastructure like Rumble so we can
help build up this parallel ecosystem of
technology so we can become more
resilient to censorship but don't forget
to also smash the like button right now
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and Super Chat any
questions it also helps the show we read
your super chats at around 9 30. we
obviously can't read every single one
but we try to read as many as we can
let's jump into the first big news from
timcast.com Biden admin has suspended
the disinformation governance board the
board's executive director Anita
jankowicz announced her departure from
the Department of Homeland Security 30.
so um just right off the bat it was a
terrible idea I don't think he's doing
this because of free speech I think it's
polling poorly among Democrats Bill
Maher came out on his show and said
these are not bright people in
government so when you get Bill Maher on
his show to a million liberals saying
this is bad don't be surprised then when
they're like oh we got a midterm coming
up and we're losing well wait I mean how
do we know this is true or not if Biden
suspended the disinformation board we do
know it in fact there was a question
about it today in the White House Press
Conference with the new press secretary
Karin Jean-Pierre Peter Ducey asked if
perhaps the disinformation governance
board was suspended due to
disinformation there we go and without a
government sport how would we know yeah
Jean-Pierre basically confirmed that yes
there was a misinformation surrounding
the disinformation governance board that
a lot of people had slammed it it's the
perfect crime it's the perfect crime
yeah that a lot of people had slammed it
um it was actually pretty amazing to see
this come down today uh that's
misinformation I don't believe it no I
mean that seriously that they were like
oh you know people were spreading lies
about it so we had to shut it down no no
no no no it was It was obviously not
lies it was obvious that people were
spreading truth about it in fact the
head of the ministry of Truth the
minister of Truth Nina jankowitz uh had
spread substantial amounts of
misinformation all by herself on her own
feeds and it was spectacular because as
soon as she was announced as soon as she
came out on Twitter and announced that
this is what she'd been working on for
the last seven months Jack pesobic went
out there and just started pulling all
of her old tweets and all of her old
things where she was talking about
Russia collusion and all of these things
uh coveted things and she was like just
spreading misinformation and
disinformation all over the place you
know what I really hope her and James
Lindsay end up in a musical together yes
did you guys see her singing okay the
whole thing people were like making fun
I was like dude for the misinformation
don't make fun of her for singing yeah
well the the political singing was real
cringe when she did them Mary Poppins
political thing I was like come on come
on come on come on come on I didn't know
what are we doing here I don't know but
the actual you know she got ragged on by
the caller I defended her when she was
doing that what do I got to do to be
famous bit I'm like yeah it was good Ian
I said I thought her singing was good
because it's not political she was just
doing a bit and she was like I want to
be famous and then Ian was like no she's
got her shoulders up and tight she's not
singing from the chest she doesn't know
what she's doing and I'm like which is
hilarious because like usually even goes
easier on people even when they say
things politically that we very much
disagree with but she's singing wrong
he's like no this is absolutely not like
we cannot he took theater yeah exactly
so he was like I am offended by this
like that's his area I studied theater
for pretty much my entire life and I
actually thought that it was kind of
cute that she was into doing performance
art even though she had this weird
government career I didn't have an issue
with the uh with that singing I did have
one I did have an issue with her coveted
misinformation Mary Poppins song I
thought that was total trash it's it's
weird how when uh When We Were Young the
adults were writing books about this
stuff when we weren't even alive the
books that were coming out were like the
future dystopia men have steal Jaws from
the war and metal Limbs and cyborgs rule
all and the government comes and bangs a
giant sword on the ground do as you're
told and what we really got was this
permanent child who was singing Mary
Poppins going we're gonna block your
news and it's like it's it's
substantially creepier you know
Millennials aren't growing up no but
they don't want to and in part
Millennials aren't growing up because
adults have told them that adulthood is
bad we come up with words like adulting
there's some problem with responsibility
ability and it's like just grow up be
responsible why it's not bad the thing
too is it's like when you were a kid
remember when you were a kid and
everyone wanted to grow up I don't know
if you guys had that and people were
like oh I could buy all the toys I want
I'll get to eat all the candy that I
want and it's like now it's like yeah
you do get to do that I mean it turns
out you do like I buy ice cream and I
put it in my fridge in my freezer and
then we eat it when I was when I was
like uh 20 I just one day was like you
know what's one thing I always thought I
would do it never did I'm gonna go to
the store and buy a whole thing of
cookie dough just walk around eating it
nice so I went to the grocery store I
grabbed a thing of cookie dough I bought
it started eating it and some little
kids saw me and he went oh as he watched
as I walked faster it gets better and
I'm like I looked and I was like hey I'm
like that's right I bite it and then
five minutes later I went oh I didn't
see the aftermath like this is why my
parents said you don't do these things
by the way I meant James O'Keefe not
James Lindsay
that doesn't make any sense yeah unless
you're talking about like a sword
movement yeah no James Lindsay would
never be in a musical no maybe no they
wouldn't allow it that's funny because I
pictured James O'Keefe when you said
James Lindsay because I knew that he had
done the thing that would be funny too
because she like
the left thinks James O'Keefe is just
like the king of disinformation and
manipulation and the right calls Nina
jankowicz the minister of Truth so like
I think what we have right Leo and
Juliet with James O'Keefe what we have
is a Broadway show like what we need is
investors that's all we need this would
sell this would sell out how much do we
need I'll fund it right like what do we
need for a Broadway show like uh start
with half a million something
so here's my serious question though is
when you look at the DHS disinformation
board and you look at Nina jankowicks
they literally put a child in charge of
a of the Department of Homeland Security
and the issue is the adults
people who are more mature and more
understanding aren't in these jobs well
what they did was they put a fool in
charge of the Department of Homeland
Security they put my orcas in charge and
he came out shortly after Biden was
inaugurated and said to immigrants all
across the world we're not saying don't
come we're saying don't come now and
then he proceeded to deny that replete
repeatedly that he had said it and he
did say it and he did mean it and that's
that's why we have so many people
storming the Border yeah I got a good
idea for a cartoon you can do Sheamus
yeah I actually is this about Biden
saying okay it is the disinformation
board announcing they're shutting down
and then all the journalists are like
writing it down and they're like
breaking news and as they're doing it
Nina jankowicz presses a button and then
the whole stage like goes down into a
sub base where it's like they walk into
the generals like we've increased your
funding by three billion dollars that's
not the whole thing was just this
information no they're going to get the
misinformation boards going out of
business all our misinformation has to
go misinformation of the dollar 20 off
all this information should that's
clever I like that and then you
highlight Nina jankowicks's uh tweets
and the things she said oh my God it's
funny because when she said that thing
about uh the laptop she's like Joe Biden
says 50 different people said this was
like it was clearly disinformation or
misinformation whichever one you want to
pick and she was like I was just quoting
the president it's like okay so by your
standard you're spreading disinformation
thank you did you correct it no I mean
was that an excuse if Trump said
something that was adjudicated to have
been false by the fact Checkers could
you say I was just repeating what the
president said well not this information
actually uh as you know whenever Trump
would make a claim and the media called
him a liar he would just say well that
would have that's what I was doing and
the media would go oh we got it we'll
retract that like Trump we have to Trump
was in fact told that he was that
actually that's a funny thing what if a
journalist you know Donald Trump said uh
you know this this will cost x amount of
dollars and they're like how does that
make sense that's not true well that's
what I was told so a journalist actually
investigates and they find the person
who told Trump that and they're like
fact check true Donald Trump was told
this it was Corn Pop they formed an
alliance yeah I'm trying to understand
who this was originally angled to try to
appeal to in the budget Administration
was the MSNBC liberals I don't
understand do you think it was to appeal
to anyone or do you think it was just to
try to shut people up well what they
were actually trying to do if you look
at what their documentation says in the
first place their goal was to dispel
disinformation outside of the U.S
um
right no no like about immigration and
stuff so months and months ago the White
House Press Secretary uh Jen saki had
talked about how one of the bind
administration's plans to get people to
stop trying to come to the U.S illegally
was to uh give proper information in
those locales to tell them like actually
don't come so I think this was part of
that effort that was sort of the idea
but there's so little good will for the
Biden administration at this point they
spread all kinds of ridiculous
misinformation and disinformation that
coming out with something like this
there would they had no chance it
doesn't you know if they had come out
and said uh this is part of our plan to
get immigrants to not come to the U.S
we're going to tell them not to come and
gave it some sort of name like that it
would have been much better received uh
I think because a lot of people would
like there to be more security at the
border yeah well I mean their entire
regime depends upon spreading
misinformation right when they came out
and they were saying things like the
reason we have higher prices is because
store owners are greedy right and it's
Putin's fault that we have high gas
prices I mean Joe Biden said
that to tackle inflation we're going to
make the corporations or what do you say
makes the rich make the rich pay more
taxes and then Peter Ducey was like how
does making rich people pay more taxes
lower inflation well that counters all
there's arguments about how rich people
they also say rich people don't
stimulate spending they just hoard all
the money I find that logic taxing them
could never curb in my favorite is that
Joe Biden launched his campaign off of
misinformation and also they wanted
Charlottesville stuff yeah they should
he sure did and writtenhouse and
everything and he lied about that not to
mention that he's run before he the
Charlottesville ever happened
here he's lied all the time and he's
plagiarized everything yep yep he's
going to come out and be like I'm going
to tackle this information
I came up with that and then you're it's
like there's a guy standing next to him
who's like writing it down and he's like
I guess
yeah it's pretty sad but it's pathetic
it's just that this is a regime which
repeatedly says things that are
verifiably untrue I mean we're not just
talking about a situation where someone
might be using facts which are true to
construct a narrative that we disagree
with like saying that businesses are
raising their prices just because of
corporate greed is an unbelievably
insane and easily falsifiable thing to
say I did did businesses just get greedy
after we flooded the economy with extra
money yes oh okay well never mind I've
been fact checked they're all greedy
yeah there's something greedy that's why
they're that's why they're trying so
hard to hire people yeah well and
offering all of these signing bonuses to
do so and what's fascinating to me is
like they just became greedy after a
bunch of money was injected into the
economy like that's when they decided to
become greeting raised prices
interesting also it's interesting that
uh Biden Administration is currently
looking to reduce sanctions on Venezuela
in order to gain oil exports from that
country as though Venezuela is some
perfectly fine place like why did we
have sanctions they haven't made any
changes it says it's just that we want
this stuff yeah and same with Saudi
Arabia if it was Donald Trump I think we
would have been able to get something
out of the Saudis but might be a whole
other conversation yeah
let's talk about Taylor Lorenz so we got
the story from the Washington Post how
the Biden Administration let right wing
attacks derail its disinformation
efforts I don't understand why the
Washington Post doesn't label this stuff
opinion and I don't understand why News
Guard gives them a 100 of 100 when they
don't label opinion in it she says right
here that disinformation has emerged as
an urgent and important issue important
to whom that's your opinion hey why
don't you put an opinion on this people
see this stuff and they think it's facts
it is not it is Taylor Lorenz opinion on
what happened so anyway in the article
she falsely claims it was right-wing
disinformation that derailed it when
Bill Maher on his show came out and said
this is ridiculous these are not bright
people what are they doing Bill Maher
one of the most prominent liberal voices
said this is bad but it was all the
right wing now you know what I'm
offended by
she doesn't give Bill Maher any of the
credit and she gives it all to you yeah
she gives it to the best
she claims that the post millennial was
part of this uh campaign to take down
the disinformation governance board
um and you know perhaps we were perhaps
we should take some credit for that um
uh no she she um she wasn't actually
she's never reached out to us she
blocked me on Twitter I found that out
one time when I reached out to her for a
comment about how she had doxed lips of
tick tock for no apparent reason and she
blocked me on Twitter it was completely
unreasonable all I did was put up a
billboard in Times Square saying that
she docks Libs of tick tock and then she
blocked me and Sheamus are you blocked
by Taylor let's see
whether I'm like a real concern are you
black I'm blocked I don't know really
yeah
hold on I wish you might have blocked
people by like if you like a blacklist
yeah yeah well I'm on a lot of those
what's what's interesting though is that
she's claiming that we does up Nina
jankowitz's past social media posts and
published articles to generate generate
controversy it was not to generate
controversy it was to expose exactly who
was the minister of Truth who was
running this bogus organization who was
running this operation to expose who it
was that the Biden Administration
thought it was worthwhile to put in
charge of something this serious someone
who had spread disinformation themselves
someone who had you know essentially
called for censorship and someone who
clearly should not be trusted to give
accurate or truthful information it is
extremely ironic because Jack pesobic
just found jankowitz's early tweets and
released them and he took it it's ironic
because that's the first thing Taylor
Wren does when she tries to make a hit
piece on somebody they just look up
their old tweets so this is what Glenn
Greenwald pointed out he said according
to Taylor Lorenz you are not allowed to
dig into the private information of
high-ranking Homeland Security officials
but it's okay to go after an anonymous
person who has bad ideas no exactly like
when did the role of journalists become
being tattletales on your average person
like someone on Twitter said something
that I don't like exactly when that
happens almost always hasn't it that
happened like the average person it
happened with me too it happened with me
too because that was the first time when
it was acceptable to just start telling
Tales out of school about somebody's bad
date I think I think I view journalists
like mini me like Dr Evil is the
government and Mini-Me is just like you
know well I mean you made this point
that it's always what they've done I
agree with you that it's it's always
been very much corrupt I mean the
mainstream media in this country has
been has it been a disaster for a lot
longer than people realize but it's the
going after like everyday average random
people thing which is is very strange
and yeah they're they're
there are creepy weirdo authoritarians
running all of most of our institutions
when you look at the Supreme Court leaks
like these crack pots these these people
are in everything they they have no uh
regard for
um for tradition or culture and I'm not
saying all tradition and all culture I'm
saying they have no regard for Community
they have no regard for any kind of
norms respect they have I I imagine they
have their their moral compass their
their um
nothing they don't even have care In
fairness that's just literally nothing
they're just confused angry people well
they think that they're doing the right
thing I don't believe that you don't
think that they think they're doing the
right thing I think they think that
they're doing the appropriate Thing by
leaking this information I I I I think
they're NPCs you think Taylor Lorenz is
an NPC I no oh no no I think Taylor
Lorenz is the perfect example of a shot
of a modern shock jock I I think you
know based on conversations I've had
with people in the industry it's it
seems to me it's my opinion
that um she was hired specifically to
generate outrage and controversy by
writing shock content that is bordering
on defamation the goal being why are we
talking about the Washington Post now
because she writes something that's a
clear opinion not labeled as opinion
knowing it all it'll anger a lot of
people she accuses only the right
ignores Bill Maher which will clearly
the right will be like hey you can't say
like that's not true and you're wrong
and then shows will produce segments
where we'll talk about her it will
generate earned press and that's what
they want so I've I've had some
conversations
I'm trying to get better confirmation
but my understanding is that the people
at the post are well aware of it that
there are veteran journalists who throw
up in their mouths a little bit every
day because they they're sickened by
what the paper has become because they
know she was brought on specifically as
a shock jock as a culture Warrior shock
Jack to generate Scandal and that's her
thing well then she does and then she
goes on TV and cries about it when
people don't like what she writes for
better or worse I think reporting's
always had this issue where people have
been activists but the more I get
involved and the more I pay attention to
the news the more I realize that it's
almost everybody that's an activist
reporter nowadays it's fine it's hard to
find anybody who isn't really just
trying to back up their priors this is
extremely true with Taylor ends but
she's not the only one
no definitely not definitely not I mean
I've probably brought him up a million
times on this show but we talk a bit
about Walter Durante every now and again
I mean this is uh this is very literally
stuff we're going back to what the 30s
here and the fact that he was covering
up the Soviet genocide because he was
himself a communist and won a Pulitzer
for it and their winning pulitzers for
fake news to this day I don't think they
rescinded that pulse they did not
receive that's what it was through
because they didn't rescind it either
which is insane we got we we've talked
about doing our own journalistic awards
ceremony to like counter the pulitzers I
would not call it that that's a terrible
name yeah
um but we would we would call it
something
maybe like the uh
the the truth award that's great
branding like if you call your social
network truth so yeah that's what Trump
would call it and I think you should
call it that no I think it's terrible
idea a lot of people
yeah people someone pointed out I saw a
tweet they're like why didn't he call it
kafifi like that everybody clever it
would have been like download the kafifi
app and everybody would want it oh
that's true Trump's app and you need a
weird name but it's like truth and then
you like post truths I hate that I hate
posting truth there's a disinformation
like you post anything that's not true
you're kicked off the website like
that's it I'm gonna read truth
terrible that actually sounds uh that
sounds like something the disinformation
governance board would do they would
read truth I think the uh the
institutions are in Decay I think that
the culture war is split between those
and the know and those who are not in
the know it has nothing to do with your
with your political positions because I
think everyone here has varying
political positions we all disagree with
each other on because we've had these
conversations before to a great degree
including foreign war or abortion but we
all agree on basically what's the fact
and so if that's what unites this table
and the people watching we're like okay
what's true and what's not true what can
be verified what's not verified and then
the other side of the culture War are
people who have no idea the Democrats
tried to uh create make a legal a path
towards third trimester or you know late
term abortions well they did it's right
there in the well they didn't read the
book I mean I'm sorry they didn't read
the bill oh so I read the bill but
that's exactly it so if if I read the
bill and I'm like that's what it says
why does it say that and then we have a
liberal Progressive on the show who are
like no no no it's like did you read the
bill no you have to read the bill that
was like the parental rights and
education Bill no one read that bill
either and so you had a bunch of people
coming out including Mark Hamill just
being like yay gay and it's like what
are you doing like no one is prohibited
from saying that children don't teach
them about weird sex acts and it's it it
literally when they were all screaming
gay over and over again I'm like imagine
being in a daycare and all the kids are
yelling neener and neener and you're
like kids be quiet kids stop yelling
that I I oh and they're all going me no
need and they won't they won't stop
that's what it is yes they're all
yelling something and you're like why
are you yelling this some kid goes hey
if you yell neither neither they're
gonna get us ice cream so they all start
screaming you're like I'm not gonna do
that that's not children yes they don't
know what they're talking about they're
too arrogant to actually read it they
believe this these psychotic ramblings
of people like Taylor Lorenz and then we
have to deal with the problems when they
go and vote for nonsensical garbage yes
like children suddenly believing that
they are actually the opposite sex just
because they came up with it randomly
it's crazy because you're not aware of
towels here in these larger narratives
Almost Doesn't Matter it doesn't matter
what the bill says as long as you're
allowed to run on it and are able to run
on it as like the don't say gay bill
that's the only thing that people know
and that was disinformation that was
disinformation nation and it was
repeated by the White House over and
over again it was repeated in the
briefing room you know it's
disinformation that Joe Biden says that
the you know best course forward is
gender affirmation telling parents to
affirm their children and it will save
their lives that's disinformation
um this White House consistently spreads
falsehoods and claims that it's true
well how about how about we talk about
those falsehoods we've got this report
from Newsweek half of Joe Biden's
Twitter followers are fake
that's disinformation I believe this
people are going you're telling me he
got 80 million followers
I believe this was true also we were
looking at this today at post millennial
I think this was also true of Justin
Trudeau's Twitter followers most of them
are what is this based on off of just so
well there's an audit company it's
called Uh spark tour so it's based on
dinesha's documentary because I'm really
cynical about this stuff only because I
know when you sign up to Twitter you're
gonna get like three people it's gonna
be like Joe Biden Elon Musk and like
Jack or something and like so I'd
understand
why so I'd like to look at I don't know
I'd like to understand the methodology a
little bit what's going on I don't know
if they reveal their methodology and I
think they said uh fake or spam accounts
and it's uh I'm sorry that was a musk
that was musk well I guess they said
there was like this tweet harvesting
it's not clear how musk arrived at the
20 figure he figured oh well and change
the series of tweets anyway so there's a
couple ways to do it I think Elon may
have made a mistake when agrawal said it
was less than five percent he said of
daily active users of their active users
the fake accounts comprise of less than
five percent
Elon Musk based on this said all users
must be around 20 so there's a
difference there are a lot of users that
don't do anything they're counting
monthly or daily active users or
whatever but I believe this is
um likely true
because it's the POTUS account whenever
a bot or a Spam bot will sign up it's
going to follow prominent accounts to
try and look real and of course it's
going to follow the president so that
it's like following a bunch of verified
accounts and here's a big one well isn't
it funny how like it's a bunch of
accounts
with people who we know are not the
actual person following an account that
we know is not being tweeted by the
actual person either
yeah exactly well Elon Musk says
whoever's controlling the teleprompter
but yeah Donald Trump actually was
tweeting what if there is no denial
to write those things he was tweeting
from the bathroom Donald Trump as
president everybody tweets he would
watch you can you imagine somebody like
I was Donald Trump's tweet writer like
putting that on your resume no it was
Trump well not there's no way anyone
else said anything would you imagine a
staffers outside the bathroom reading a
tweet just being like he would watch Fox
News and then he would tweet it right
away and you'd be like Tucker said this
or did you hear about this then he would
go to rallies and he'd repeat it it was
really obvious that he would just watch
Fox and be like boom something happened
I I kind of I liked it I mean oh yeah
you know and and you know being a
journalist and
seeing Trump just tweet random things
was really a lot of fun you could get
like a whole bunch of Stories
on Twitter I was told by uh that it was
it was violence that every every day
they had they were there were people
journalists who were assigned to like
there were journalists at news
organizations who were told your job is
to keep refreshing Trump's Twitter feed
and then when he says something write it
up oh my goodness and they were saying
it was violence as tweets they were
saying that it was like stressful and
that they needed like you know Health
days that once once he lost the election
they're like finally it's over or I'm
sorry once he got banned they were like
like I'm crying of Joy like I can go
back to normal working now no more
stress they were saying how they would
get text messages at two in the morning
from their boss being like Trump just
tweeted write it up and they'd be like
no the world
it's really it's really not that bad
like I work from home I live in New York
City I have a job as a journalist
sometimes I have to write things at 2
a.m and it's like it's totally fine I
have no problem doing that
as we saw with my Twitter up the Twitter
leaks from veritas this guy said he
worked what four hours in the last
quarter
yeah he did their children they don't
want to work the craziest thing is I saw
someone post something where they were
like
uh I said something about all of my
friends who are going on vacation their
summer plans and you know I'm stuck here
with the kids and I'm and I'm just like
I don't understand if he's I don't know
if he's complaining or if he's like
bragging I don't know somebody trying to
say but the conversation was basically
like the uh the dinks the Dual income no
kids people were like going to travel
and partying living a good life and it's
like I don't you know what I don't get
I'll I'll I'll segue sort of why
everybody wants to be younger I don't
get that either it's like you you I mean
I don't want to be older either but I
don't want to be younger well I don't
care either way it's like you live you
grow you age and then I think aging is
going to be painful I'm not really quite
looking forward to that oh we're all
like look a lot of better than the
alternative yes
a lot of really great people who came
before us got old yeah and they died and
I'm just like why would I not want The
Human Experience yeah that is wait that
sounds like a cope I I'd want to live
longer if I could I could almost live
forever you yeah because it almost
sounds like you you say you don't want
to live forever because we don't have
the opportunity to and I'm saying that
to make myself feel better you know
what's funny is I have this same debate
with my son who is 12 and we talk about
whether or not you'd want to live
forever and I'm always like yeah you'd
want to live forever that's amazing you
know you could see everything you could
see how the the human story comes to a
final conclusion like what really
happens and he's like yeah but you'd
have to watch all the people that you
love and care about die why would you
want to do that Mom yeah but that's
that's not the issue the issue is after
you know a good 30 years you're like I
understand humans
yeah I don't think there's anything you
know I mean maybe maybe you'll watch I
don't want to live forever maybe you'll
watch technology develop and then you'll
get to the point where you can plug your
brain to The Matrix or something but I'm
just like I would I would rather in The
Human Experience is The Human Experience
I don't understand what's a bad thing
that people want it's not a bad thing I
mean it's just well I don't understand
why it's going to be avoided I don't
think I actually avoided either
personally I look forward to being old
but if if like or the opportunities to
live further no that would be cool did
you ever see it to be like 150 something
like that remember when Johnny Knoxville
dressed up like an old man and just
cause trouble
better it's because people are like he's
an old guy what are you gonna do about
it you know so are you saying that's
going to be you as an old man like
Grandpa Simpson yeah not Grandma Simpson
like Johnny Knoxville was doing like he
would walk in he would just like grab a
bunch of groceries and just like walk
away but they're like he's just an old
guy he's confused I don't know what
Grandpa Simpson does he says that they
let you shoplift oh okay okay well there
you go well I wouldn't shoplift but you
know when you're old it's just like you
just go and do it's like it's like
you've got nothing left to lose the
world's your oyster you know go
skydiving and you're like when you're
like 90 yes you could run for president
why go skydiving you could still be
president I think Bernie Sanders is
about to run again soon
yeah I do I think I think Donald Trump
was probably thinking that he was
talking about like kids and stuff I I
look forward to the summer because
because I have to travel a lot for work
and I'm looking forward to the summer
because I'm gonna take my son with me to
all of the places that I have to go and
I'm stoked this can be awesome that
sounds beautiful right we're gonna like
I'm really hoping I can find good hotels
with nice pools this is what I'm this is
what I'm hoping for for my summer how do
we get into immortality from bots on
Twitter well because because robots
never die
yeah those Bots are going to carry Joe
Biden's wisdom into the future Tim
the person running Joe Biden's account
is actually a bot Elon doesn't audit
okay that would not be surprising the
person standing at the podium is
actually a bot if you look at the
ridiculous things that his account
tweets out
it would be really funny if just like
one day when Joe was like stuttering a
guy walked up with like a screwdriver
and like bopped him on the arm and then
like jiggled him and then he was like oh
the economy has been in Dire Straits for
some time it's like no he would never
admit that percussive mate in the
maintenance I think they call it no like
he's malfunctioning Sparks are coming up
Biden thinks Putin is running the
country and that's why everything's
going to hell well I saw a conspiracy uh
pyramid a while ago Tim and I believe it
had Biden is a robot as one of the
conspiracy there's actually let me
double check let me tell let me double
check was a robot that's that that's
like conspiracy theories are usually
negative right it's like a bad thing is
happening if mine was a robot oh that's
a good that's pretty good you know
because like right now it wouldn't be
such a bad robot he's not a bad robot
I'm worried about Biden's capabilities
to do the job and it turned out he's
actually a robot I'd be like oh okay you
know you know Biden's in in poor health
but robots all right I think we should
be concerned about Biden's ability to
run the country oh one million percent
we I mean I we should have been
concerned during the primaries we were
we were it's really terrifying to see
someone who is uh as Dotty and confused
as this old man is actually try to lead
the entire
World essentially isn't it which is the
job I mean the fact that the Democratic
party even picked it like they had other
options they had other options
like if the idea was that anyone could
beat Trump why not run Buddha judge
right there's like no we have them now
anyway he's out there fixing potholes
what do you think about Elon he tweeted
that he's uh officially running as a
republic I'm sorry he's
not calm down
Hold On by the way I have to say so I
pulled the conspiracy theory pyramid up
again yes Biden is a robot is a
conspiracy theory on there not only that
but it is a theater that it was a
theater a theory that makes you a danger
to yourself and others to believe
so Elon Musk tweeted in the past I've
voted Democrat because they were mostly
the kindness party but they have become
the party of division and hate so I can
no longer support them and will vote
Republican now watch their dirty tricks
campaign against me unfold and he also
then tweets political attacks on me will
escalate dramatically in coming months
yep what do you guys think does it
matter
is it something we all have experienced
ourselves and know already I think one
thing that it shows is how far to the
left the Republican party has actually
moved yeah it's substantially to the
left of what it used to be and you can
tell because people like Elon Musk are
going to vote Republican after a
lifetime of voting Democrat I'm
essentially a conservative because the
Democrats have gone so far to the left
and I stayed right here and the
Republicans came over and I was like oh
hey fellas exactly no it's true and I
hear so many people say that the only
time I've ever heard someone say
something along the lines of I'm on the
left just because the Republican party
has gone so far right is when they're on
corporate media and they're some Rhino
right right it's like oh no one in real
life says that ever it's like 60 year
old it's not true 60 year old
millionaire warmonger who's like I don't
know I don't recognize my party anymore
yes the Democrats want to blow up kids
in the Middle East so I'm going to vote
for them it's like okay that's why I
won't that's why I won't yeah exactly
it's the same I'm super conflicted on
Elon Musk continuing to like evolve and
put his hands more into politics because
he's going to be another billionaire
potentially funding candidates in the
future he might be another Peter Thiel
type figure in the future so it'll be
interesting to see how he changes and
develops but I am highly I wonder why he
would fund any politicians do you do we
really because he's trying to get
involved in politics or one way or
another and like Twitter President right
um
but it wouldn't be worth it for him to
run he could just have his paws on
different elections by funding people
but what I was trying to get to in a
full circle kind of way is that he still
has deep connections to China he still
has Tesla factories in China and he will
still be at the whim of this government
the Chinese government the Communist
Chinese government that is if he does
want to do any business there in the
future he needs to make sure he doesn't
step on any toes I know he kind of
overlooked that because musk has become
this sort of anti-left figure and when
we don't know that we talk about all the
time but what that Elon Musk has praised
China on more than one occasion he's got
factories in China sure but he's kind of
become a hero in some online anti-left
circles because he is a big voice
willing to come out against these people
and it seems as though all you have to
do nowadays to be get a lot of fans on
Twitter and say the obvious that men
can't become women or something like
that so it's just P I think people ought
to be cautious who they end up
supporting being reactionaries against
others if you think about saying men
can't become women on Twitter a month
ago that would have gotten you banned
from the platform uh maybe maybe
Twitter's bands are it's a it's a cast
system the more followers you have the
more you can say so I said I tweeted
what did I tweet don't cut off teenage
girls tits and uh someone reported me
and they got an email from it's like
from Twitter and it was like you've been
reported under German law or whatever
and we found no violation whenever I
Tweet stuff like this people are like oh
Tim's gonna get banned now and I'm like
you kidding dude I got a million
followers not gonna ban me well the
Babylon B got banned for saying that uh
oh I know Rachel Levine who's obviously
a man as well that's because uh and it
was Twitter's policy is going to be
targeted individually say yeah so if you
if you say it generality then they they
give you more leeway if you have a small
account like 100 followers and you say
you know men and women are different or
something they'll ban you if you have a
big account like the Babylon being said
men are different they'd leave you alone
but they said Rachel Levine specifically
is it too cliche to say that double
mastectomies or modern day uh lobotomies
almost in a way well they don't they
don't remove your brain they don't
remove the same thing but just as we
look at back on the bottom he's now sort
of medical malpractice is how in the
future we will look back I mean it's
it's certainly an anti-mother operation
yeah I think it's like a butchering it's
like the next stage of plastic surgery
and kind of a butchering of a body yeah
I don't want to deviate too far from
what we were talking about because we
are going to talk about this in just a
second sure so talking about Elon and
Twitter wolf around the top of Elon I
just want to respond to what you said I
totally agree I've said this in the past
I'm cautiously optimistic about Elon I'm
not totally sold and it's absolutely
true all someone has to say is I'm not
complete lately all the way on the far
left with respect to one single issue or
I think the left has gone too far here
and all of a sudden the right wing is
all over that person yeah and there's
also a lot of parallels between Elon
Musk and somebody who's commonly
demonized Bill Gates I mean these are
both people who had their come UPS in
the tech industry and some of the stuff
Elon Musk says is crazier than what Bill
Gates says Elon Musk is the chip planter
well the difference
Elon Musk and Bill Gates Romeo and
Juliet I will say and they're both
billionaires they're both you know the
richest people that existed during their
time period during the top but Bill
Gates gets demonized like no other and
Elon Musk becomes a hero of the same
people well the same people who will
complain about Bill Gates being some
demonic you know cabal man will praise
Elon Musk for the simplest things on
Twitter sure
though if I if I may that's the Broadway
show Nina jankowitz plays Elon Musk
as Juliet and uh James O'Keefe plays
Bill Gates as Romeo so that's the show
to your point I hear in but so the
reason I consider myself cautiously
optimistic about Elon Musk but I don't
like Bill Gates comes down to really one
really important issue it's that Bill
Gates has repeatedly said things like
there are too many people in this world
he's discussed population control
whereas Elon Musk is basically the only
ultra wealthy person saying we need more
people
great chips no I'm not I'm not a fan of
the brain chips yeah yeah exactly I'm
not a fan of the brain but I think it's
gotten to the point where there are so
few Elites saying anything even remotely
sane that when one of them does it's a
victory and doesn't he have a bunch of
kids yes I know Bill Gates also has a
history with his like Father supporting
uh Margaret Thatcher or Sanger in the
past with connections with Planned
Parenthood but I still think you know if
you want to extrapolate what Elon Musk
says with the brain chips it's just as
bad as anything I think Bill Gates has
said in particular so it's just I think
it's an interesting thing
about the brain chips I think he said
he's talking about narrow link yeah yeah
so neural link is I mean it's a pretty
fascinating tool and if it's used
properly I think it would really help
people who are disabled
okay right right so one of the things
that can help do is people who have
spinal injuries it can help connect
their brain to other parts of the body
and Bill Gates is trying to cure
different diseases
so that's why this is a moot point my
question is what does Elon Musk is going
to force the chip into people's brains
well offering up a service that you
don't like and don't think is creepy is
bad we can criticize it people who do
bad things but the question around here
is around Freedom Bill Gates has called
for rescinding freedoms saying how is
how is Elon going to stop misinformation
you can't do this he said we need less
people and Bill Gates said that and Elon
Musk has said we actually need more
people to stay in the planet and people
should have freedom of speech now the
things they work on we can criticize but
when we're specifically talking about
Elon and things we like it's for the
things we like and when we criticize
them it's for the things we don't like
and the end result I believe is
supporting freedom of speech where and
and defending the rights of humans or
saying people are good and we need more
of them
will probably create a better outcome in
the long run no matter what he works on
in terms of neuralink Bill Gates saying
the opposite is darkness that will lead
us on a very dark path of death and
suffering yeah I actually totally agree
with that and I do
um I do like this idea that we need more
people because uh we need people to
support the people that already exist
and we need to create more resources and
human beings are the best resource the
planet has I I don't completely agree
that
um you know we've talked about
overpopulation and there are a lot of
people who say actually let me try and
find Google Earth
there are a lot of people who say that
um were not overpopulated uh and as that
that's an opinion I think you guys have
right yeah have you ever looked at a map
of the United States
yes yes have you ever actually looked
and down at the level of development in
North America
like it's only really popping on the
coasts no I mean you can no no the
entirety everything when you look at
pull up we've got we don't say
development I mean like when when you
see pictures see where the lights are
human altering terrain doesn't matter
where the lights are grab Illinois for
instance and when you zoom in basically
the entirety of the state has been
developed there are some pockets of
trees in some state parks but you can
just go straight through the state in
any direction and every little square is
human development why is that bad so I'm
not saying that's bad but I'm certainly
saying when the entirety of Illinois or
other states are completely developed we
overpopulation is something that I think
we should discuss or entertain well
shouldn't we then people maybe should
move to other places
they don't live there we've taken the
land and we've cut it and developed it
to produce a certain thing so perhaps we
could say maybe we're not overpopulated
but we're over producing we are utilized
Rising massive swaths of millions of you
know Acres or whatever
to produce all of this all the all this
food and all these resources that we're
consuming like crazy maybe if humans
consumed less we might not have to worry
about over development we're shipping
and fertilizer from from Europe Norman
Borlaug has increased crop yield but
nutrient density has diminished
substantially so I I think as much as I
you know I respect Elon Musk saying
things like more people is better than
less people because when you say less
people really bad things happen yeah I
think we should try and make sure we're
having a legitimate conversation maybe
I'm wrong but I can point to a few
things that I think at least would need
to be questioned like the bug population
collapses uh the dead the dead zones in
in the in the ocean fishery collapse and
mass pollution maybe it's not
overpopulation you know we talked with
Michael Mouse about this it may be over
pollution or over development or
something exactly so I think you hit the
nail on the head with that last
statement my issue with the idea of this
being an overpopulation issue framing
the narrative that way is that you are
with that framing indicating what the
solution has to to be in your mind so
it's circular if you say we have an
overpopulation problem that way then
what you're effectively saying is the
solution is for there to be less people
right the salute well but but if you
point out the way you did that there
there are issues such as you know insect
populations declining if that's the case
or pollution then we ask the question
how can we deal with these problems and
there's no reason to believe the
solution is to get rid of people or have
less people I agree with that 100 I
think the solution is actually
um better agricultural technology and
development I believe it is culture I
think the United States has cultural
problems I think we all agree with that
yeah I think we have we have a culture
of gluttony instead of responsibility
amen I think that is a problem
absolutely so you have you have people
who are morbidly obese and instead of
being like maybe I should consume less
they're like this is fine actually let's
get on the cover of a magazine and tell
everyone else to live this way too I
think we have a parenting problem as
well because I think that parents don't
teach their children to be responsible
either for themselves or for others and
I think that that is a key thing to do
like children you know stop worrying
about what college your kids are going
to go to or what career they're going to
have and instead teach your kids to grow
up to be kind responsible people who can
take care of themselves and the people
that they love and who also want to I
think that's what's so and find joy in
it find joy in it yeah
yeah we I mean I saw a post not long ago
and you see a lot of this from people
saying things like
you know so much of our life is
dedicated to work and I I do believe
that at some point people can be
overworked 100 and that's a problem but
they were saying things along the lines
of you know the only thing meaningful
about my life is when I'm off work and I
think a lot of that is firstly an issue
with the kinds of jobs people have now
there's a good argument to be made for
that but also that no one finds any
value in the service of others and
people don't take any pride in doing
things that make other people's lives
easier but the other thing too is that
we have completely diminished the value
of just doing work yeah right I mean if
there's a job worth doing and this is
cliche but there's a reason it's cliche
if there's a job worth doing it's worth
doing as well as you possibly can you
know there was recently I forget what it
was but sometimes there'll be like an
article at work and I'm going to be
writing it at post-millennial and
sometimes I think like you know I don't
really feel like writing this and then I
think okay if you don't feel like
writing it clearly you're missing
something clearly you're missing some
aspect of this story go figure it out do
some research investigate it find out
the interesting part of it and then
write it and whenever that happens oddly
those end up being my best pieces the
ones where I'm not sure at first and I'm
just kind of like eh and then I dig into
it and I'm like oh that's actually
fascinating and now I have a great piece
we were talking about transitions a
moment ago so I wanted to hold off
because we have a story here actually
this is a tweet from Colin Wright good
friend of the show and it's actually
just a repost of an Instagram post from
a female amateur skateboarder he says
female skateboarder Taylor Silverman is
speaking out after placing second to a
male competitor who identifies as a
woman at the Red Bull Cornerstone
contest Silverman and other female
skateboarders were robbed of their
achievements and prize money that was
meant for women in the post made on
Instagram Taylor Silverman said my name
is Taylor Silverman I am a female
athlete I have been skateboarding for 11
years and competing for several years I
have been in three different contests
with trans women two of which I placed
second and the last contest series I did
for Red Bull I placed second the trans
competitor who won took a thousand
dollars in the qualifiers three thousand
dollars in finals and one thousand
dollars in best trick this totaled five
thousand dollars of the prize money
meant for female athletes I took one
thousand dollars in qualifiers in 1750
for second place so 2750 in total the
girl who took third received 750 the
girl who deserved a thousand for best
truck best trick took nothing Along with
whoever would have placed third I
deserve to place first be acknowledged
for my win and get paid I reached out to
Red Bull and was ignored I am sick of
being bullied into silence
in the next post
Taylor Silverman posted the email sent
to Red Bull saying hope all is well with
you I am reaching out in hopes of being
directed to the right person to express
my concerns about what occurred at the
Red Bull Cornerstone contest with the
transgender competitor in the women's
division perhaps that is you if not
hopefully you can put me in contact with
the correct person a biological man with
a clear Advantage won the women's
division best trick and also multiple
qualifiers this took away the
opportunity that was meant for women to
place and earn money what happened was
unfair and at the time I was too
uncomfortable to speak up I understand
that in today's society even some women
think this is acceptable but I believe
in doing the right thing even if it's
not the popular thing I now realize it's
really important for me to speak up and
I'd like to schedule a time to talk
so I've announced that uh I got my math
wrong but uh um I've announced I said
timcast will gladly cover the difference
and Grant Taylor Silverman the 2250
difference lost to placing behind a male
athlete we will also be willing to cover
the total total lost revenue for the
female athletes who would have placed
higher were it not for the male athlete
now she didn't lose 22.50 she lost 12.50
because she didn't win best tricks
someone else I guess you said would have
and so the so some people have asked me
they said you know Tim you you you said
that the NCAA Women you know it's it's
too bad for them or whatever I was like
no no hold on what I said well you mean
the swimming the swimming uh I said they
are not complaining about it how can I
speak up for them if they're not
speaking out for themselves Taylor
Silverman spoke up for herself said I
don't believe this is fair and I believe
that's that's deserving of support and
also totally biased I've been
skateboarding my whole life I I had
worked with the uh organization briefly
mind you that actually got equal pay for
women at the X Games we've talked about
it quite a bit
when I saw this knowing what I know from
skateboarding for what am I going on 23
years knowing about the physical
elements knowing about the physics
Taylor Silverman is absolutely correct
and let me let me make this point before
we get into the bigger picture
some people have said uh in response to
me we had our good friend The Amazing
Atheist said women should compete in the
women's division I responded to Colin
Wright saying that men males have a
higher center of gravity what this means
is that from a standing position a man
can Ali hire a male can Ali higher than
a female females carry their center of
gravity lower which is better for
balance in a lot of ways but means
they're they're Ollie hike their jump
height will be lower there are very
clear differences and advantages that
males will have regardless of your
hormone replacement therapy
skateboarding is not a muscle-based
sport where it's like the stronger you
are the better you can be there's
there's aggressive aggression there's
grit like your willingness to take risks
and it's very much control if you have a
higher center of gravity you're going to
be able to clear higher obstacles
women also have what's called a more
pronounced Q angle that's the quadricep
angle meaning because of the wide hips
the femur and the quadriceps come at a
harsher angle than a male would
regardless of hormone replacement
therapy this means that biological
females competing at any stage are going
to be higher more prone to leg injuries
knee injuries ankle injuries a clear
Advantage for male athletes regardless
of if they're transitioning or not so
this one to me I think needs you know
I'm biased obviously but also it's gone
the story's gone viral everybody's
talking about it
um I think it's important to talk about
and I think it's important that people
like Taylor Silverman are speaking out
and saying you know I think this is not
fair now the crazy element is her post
on Instagram has something like unless I
check 11 000 comments yeah it's huge the
anti-Semitism because uh Taylor
Silverman's Jewish right right crazy
crazy and she has a star of David and
her and right these are these are the
leftists who hate Israel who believe in
these weird conspiracy theories like
like the Farrakhan stuff and are now
going after her and attacking her for
being Jewish simply because she said
this is money that was meant for female
athletes yeah I mean look the left
doesn't care about these things that
they claim to when they talk about like
racism sexism homophobia in fact despite
their vitriol they don't even really
care about the transgender issue they
just try to use these labels to accuse
anyone they think it would be useful to
get out of the public discussion
um and when it comes to their attacks on
other people they're almost always
willing to resort to these labels but
it's never talked about right so it's an
instance of I'm creating a rule
surrounding certain language about
ethnicities like slurs and then saying
we are only going to prosecute one group
of people for doing this so people on
the left can get away with it like crazy
I think they also wanted to figure out
how to make sure that white men could be
qualified as diversity hires
I think stories like these are the
biggest threat to so-called trans rights
because at this point when you get into
the sports and physically comparing the
two it's unavoidable so I know for a lot
of people they think Live and Let Live
if somebody's above 18 let them go
through the process if they want to get
these plastic surgeries to make them
look like the opposite sex fine it's not
hurting anybody but then once you get to
down to something like a competition
where the differences are obvious we're
going to be seeing more and more cases
like this well and like Leah Thomas and
women's women's rights activists know
about this women's rights rights
activists can clearly see that showing
the unfairness of men competing against
women and women's sports could be the
Turning Point needed I want to give a
shout out real quick to uh to Taylor
Silverman you can follow her on
Instagram Taylor May Silverman and I'm
and on Twitter I believe uh her Twitter
is TM Silverman but specifically because
she posted on Instagram this truth
sounds like hate to those who hate the
truth many people in her position didn't
stand like for the league Thomas there
was no woman who actually stood up only
the one who lost yeah yeah so she so
this is another interesting thing uh
Taylor spoke up um I believed in a few
months since the event
and I actually talked to where we're
we're maybe working something out uh
some kind of you know we'll do an
interview or maybe but um it's been a
few months actually since the contest
and I looked at her record
she's somebody who actually won actually
got cash she got second place you know
she she qualifies she's winning when it
came to the NCAA swim meet the only
person who spoke up was the one who got
bumped like an eighth place or whatever
it was yeah it was like what was it 17th
or something 16th place or something by
the way I made a decision and it wasn't
even her it was actually her teammate
who spoke up on her behalf oh wow I am
going to start calling all of the people
who want men dressed as women to compete
in women's sports men's rights activists
you are an MRA and you will be adopting
the language of radical feminists when
you do it and before bravo bravo shame
look when women talk I listen we didn't
we talk to Vash about that I don't know
yeah I'm pretty sure we talked about
men's rights activism I said I said I
said I don't I don't care for using the
word man or woman I'll just say male so
when I when I tweeted this we had a uh
TJ Kirk is his name right the Amazing
Atheist yeah TJ Kirk he said uh women
should compete in women's division and
then like it's it's absurd to me that
you're having a semantic argument for
what reason did we create women's
division Sports was it because sometimes
people wear dresses no it's because
there are biological differences to a
great dude 90 of the time to a great
degree uh uh between males and females
and the colloquial understanding in
Humane Society was that man and woman
meant male and female in fact the mo to
most people today it still does so when
someone says a trans woman is a woman
therefore should compete in the women's
division it's like
we didn't create the wind's division
based on the clothing you wear no we
didn't create the women's division based
on how you felt that day like oh today
I've decided Well I mean what if
someone's genderfluid and I'm serious
that's not just like a dunk on the lips
what if someone is gender fluid on the
day they feel like a woman do they
compete in the women's division the
answer would be yes there's actually a
CEO in the UK who
um makes 70 uh cents less per dollar
when when they identify as a woman that
day okay in fact there's I believe it's
a CEO who is gender fluid and some days
wears uh pencil skirts and some days
wears trousers and was honored as like
you know best woman CEO or something
like that so playing both sides for the
day when he was in the pencil skirt one
of the uh difficulties for anyone to
speak up is that they're speaking out
against people they know and that's a
big component that I think a lot of
people should understand so I know many
pro skateboarders
for years I have been told by many pro
skateboarders they're upset with what's
happening they're upset with politics
many secretly support Trump and they all
say but I cannot risk my livelihood to
speak out and so exactly well don't
don't come to me but I will say I want
to add something to this
uh there is an issue at play here and it
is a pro skateboarder that I have met
and skated with on a couple occasions
who's friends with people I know named
Leo Baker uh Leo Baker is a is a
non-binary I believe formally I believe
trans man and before that was uh was a
top female athlete named Lacey Baker and
I'm I I I I mean no disrespect but I
have questions and that question is when
Leo was competing as a as a female in
the women's division as Lacey Baker and
winning
Lacy transitions into in into Leo says
that they're trans but continues to
compete against women
so my problem is who is coming out and
saying that Taylor Silverman is wrong
when she says this why is it that a
biological male can can say that they
now identify as a woman and compete
against women but a biological female
can say I am now trans but still compete
against women it's because everyone
knows that it's fake everyone is aware
of the lie and we're supposed to just
deal with the fact that we know it's a
lie and say something that is untrue
which is exactly what happens which is
literally what happens in the book 1984.
is that you're supposed to know that you
know you you believe you believe the
truth and you speak the lie and that is
the most dangerous aspect of this what I
want to add to sorry just because
um when I saw this story I saw Colin
Wright's tweet that Taylor spoke out
that's uh look Taylor is not somebody
who is a prominent pro skateboarder with
millions of followers who can risk
speaking out and be rich these pro
skateboarders who tell me they can't
speak out I'm like you own how many
houses you have how many followers you'd
lose half of them you'd still be rich or
at the very least you'd be middle class
well JK Rowling speaks out she's spoken
she said that she has lost opportunities
she keeps speaking out she keeps act you
know being active for women's rights and
I have the utmost respect for that I
have the utmost respect for Miss
Silverman here and I hope that you know
I hope that you guys work out a great
situation
um and that she's able to be you know
continue being successful in her chosen
path
we all know that it's unreasonable when
we saw Leah Thomas swimming in the pool
against women we could all see that it
was completely a total lie that this
person should be competing against these
much shorter much smaller much less
strong women and we were just supposed
to go along with it anyway and people
did and it's it's shocking to see that
and I think that the more this happens
and the more we see women athletes start
to speak out the more hopefully the tide
will shift on this and you know Beth
Stelzer who does save women's sports is
a really fascinating person who saw this
happen and weightlifting you know she's
been Fierce and fighting on this I think
the thing you said there is women and it
needs to come from women and that's why
I think Taylor May is so commendable
here because if it doesn't come from
women I mean men could bark about this
all they want but it's women who are the
victims and are missing the
opportunities because of this so they
unfortunately in our society need to be
the most vocal about it because people
don't like listening to men so I'll
address one wait Super Chat and they're
saying that I complained that the swim
didn't speak up until after they had
lost so let's break this down first is
Tim biased yes obviously I'm a
skateboard I've been skateboarding for
for 23 years so of course this I see
this story and I'm like oh Haram you
know how dare they but there is a
difference with the NCAA they had been
consistently competing they knew it was
happening they knew it was going to
happen they had swam more than one time
there were multiple races my
understanding of this story having dug
into it and spoken with some people
involved when you go to a skateboarding
contest you don't know who you're
competing against you they say hey
there's going to be a contest in this
place at this time you go to a local
qualifier then you show up and all of a
sudden you see who you're competing
against my understanding is that this is
not an instance that's exactly the same
where this person knew I'm going to fly
to this place and compete in this
contest against a trans person it was
they showed up and said oh really now
Fair criticism it did take Taylor a few
months to speak out
and uh I think you know you need to
speak out sooner than that and that and
but that's fine I mean look man um I can
be angry and critical and I I think the
fact that she was second place one cash
could have walked away with the cash not
as much cash as she wanted but instead
she's like no no no no I've got to say
something about this because the woman
who got bumped out of the the bracket
isn't speaking up like with the NCAA the
one got bumped from the bracket was the
one who spoke out and I said you're only
speaking out because you you lost the
money well in this instance the person
who got bummed didn't speak out and the
person who did get the money is the one
speaking out and I'm like okay but but
either way either way
um
I love that they came for your sport and
you were just like no that's it
I came for swimming and I said nothing
because I do not say I I think there's a
fair element there absolutely I think I
think but I think that's great I think
that's great you know when you see it
happen in your own stuff I think it
really makes a big difference I saw this
happen in theater when suddenly grants
that were because you know there were
grants like women's plays only women
should submit plays for this and you
know proposals and whatever and then the
the granting opportunities and the
opportunities that had been specifically
for women were suddenly for women or
self-identified women and I was like
what's this about this is not reasonable
you know it's not these this is not for
playwrights who are men in dresses this
is supposed to be for women playwrights
and
everything changed I also changed very
quickly and I that's why you know that's
in part why I started speaking out about
this because I found that so infuriating
and stupid it is infuriating and it's
not as if anyone could change the the
definition of woman like men and women
are different but I do find it comical
that women were never asked no because
only when they literally never asked
dude started wearing dresses and like
this said yeah we're women and it's like
do you have opinions about that like yes
they're like no you're not allowed to
like you're not allowed imagine imagine
a situation there was no there's no
committee imagine a situation where a
six foot tall man in a dress with heels
looks down at you and says I'm a woman
are you gonna say otherwise you're like
yeah I know you're a woman oh sure okay
don't don't hurt me Mr crazy man we try
to be respectful to uh to people who are
you know we we try to be respectful as I
mentioned uh often even Ben Shapiro said
he would use preferred pronouns in a
public setting because it's just easier
than though he doesn't agree with it and
wouldn't use it in an academic or
journalistic setting we we we are the
tolerant we say I may not like it but
you know I'm on my own business you know
you do your thing and that's how gay
marriage comes to pass we're like okay
look you're gonna you're gonna get your
tax benefits you can go into your home
you can do your thing and then it's it's
funny because there's that meme
from 2000 and was it 2012 or something
which is yeah I was like what happens if
gay marriage becomes legalized and it's
like World War III will happen people
will start teaching kids about about gay
sex and it's like and here we are those
things are happening that's what's going
down let's jump to this story though
from the AP
U.S soccer equalizes pay in Milestone
with women and men they say the U.S
soccer Federation reached a milestone
agreement to pay its men and women teams
equally making the American national
governing body the first in the sport to
promise both sexes matching money oh boy
so this is why I think this is crazy
Lydia they have different pay structures
they're different leagues it would be
like imagine if Burger King announced
that they were going to be paying
McDonald's employees the same rates so
my question they bring the men up or the
women down they're the reverse they cut
the men's salary yeah it's just like
yeah all right so are they taking funds
that uh were generated by the men's
division and giving them to the women's
division because the women's division
can't make enough to pay them what they
pay them in yes I think that's what it
is so it says U.S women and men's team
agree historical to share World Cup
prize money
so uh that is very that is very
insulting
we are generating yeah so so I think the
AP was wrong what what the story is at
least from the guardian is that they're
going to share each other's prize money
with each other so are they saying that
the women should be dependent upon men's
money I find that interesting so the
best thing are going to be giving
providers I guess yes apparently the men
are going to give up large you know
Millions upon millions in the the female
athletes are going to give up hundreds
of thousands so why would men play for
the the US team why wouldn't they just
go play in Europe and make a lot of
money and not play on the national team
at all the interesting part about this
is is that the men's team is actually
trash relative to other men's soccer
teams and are for sure no our female
soccer team is one of the best in the
world right still men's soccer
yeah exactly but it's number one so it's
for America first right now then we
should be rooting for our women's team I
mean yeah but they're still generating
less money so why should they get more
yeah we should support them too we
should buy what was it I mean if people
want to survive
why aren't you dying your hair purple
just to get like Megan wrapping I did go
to activation in New York City well
there was a parade yeah when they won a
few years ago the people who wanted
something to the parade the people who
want to support the women seem like they
can watch people can get invested in
this without having to take from the
men's team and it's funny because you
mentioned the men's team is not that
good I don't follow sports but I've
heard that but it's not as if anyone's
saying well you know we should be giving
the trophies that the women win to the
men's team because we just like men more
what we're saying is if a group of
people earn a certain amount of money
they should get that amount of money and
if a group of people earns less than
that you don't redistribute it to make
them feel better well it's a socialists
especially when they're making money
playing sports they have a dream job
they're an athlete you do and you're in
a communist yeah right is a socialist
soccer team yeah yeah you know it's
funny which makes sense because it is a
European sport right no one's no
American I love when the the the blue
checkies journalists were like the women
actually win and the men end up the men
are getting paid more money and it's
like the men negotiate a different pay
structure that was literally it well
there's also different audiences there
were bonuses or guarantees and the women
want to give the men wanted bonuses or
something so it's like the man got bonus
money and made money and the women
didn't or something but but also yeah
it's just like imagine someone working
at McDonald's and they're like this
McDonald makes a million dollars per
month and then across the streets of
Burger King's only making like 500 000
per month so the Burger King employees
get angry and go on strike and say it's
not fair that McDonald's employees get
paid more than us it's like you're
different businesses I get you both sell
cheeseburgers but you're different
businesses so then they agree to share
their salaries like okay sure I guess so
yeah that doesn't make any sense at all
either
so do like if the men win they have to
give money to the women or something I
think they're going to be less
incentivized to win you're not making
much money
he's gonna advise to play on this team
so wait hold on well you said the men's
team is really bad so does that mean the
men aren't going to win and aren't going
to make money and so the women's team
isn't gonna end up making this money
from the men anyway I think it's more
MRI
the the the the people supporting women
here their men's rights activists who
think well what if we be getting uh
alimony what if we got uh trans women to
fail the women's league instead
but they would have to I guess we could
right well I'm sorry are they trying to
exclude trans women from their space so
the issue that I had with the uh well
the question is are there any trans
women on the women's soccer team we
don't even know that and if there are
well maybe clearly bigotry obviously
true yeah well I mean you know the
argument from the left on this is uh
again you know the Amazing Atheist
tweeted at me that you know tall people
are better at basketball we don't ban
tall people and it's like okay so then
for what reason don't we just like seek
out only trans women to play in the WNBA
who are going to be taller or in women's
soccer who are on average going to be
substantially taller and have more bone
density and muscle mass
the the point I was bringing up with the
skateboarding thing is that people like
to mention strength you know it's like
in in swimming your strength matters
your strength and endurance matters and
uh but in skateboarder doesn't in
skateboarding it is control it is timing
and the advantage of having a higher
center of gravity of having you know
narrower hips no matter what you do or
change that that's not gonna have an
impact I'm wondering if in the Escape
contest I don't think they have any um
uh hormone requirement like some some
sport leagues do where it's like you got
your testosterone has to be a certain
level because that wouldn't matter
anyway in which case my point is
are we gonna come to the point where if
the argument is based on gender as a
social construct and not sex
then someone who's literally a six foot
six 250 pound muscular male could just
be like
I'm a woman like zooby right when zooby
did the deadlift and said he was a woman
why not
that that should be completely
permissible under their ideology yes yes
in which case the women's I gotta say
why how about for women's soccer we
should get a bunch of males and I'm not
saying this disparagingly or or as a
gotcha it's a real question I think I
think you're just being inclusive Tim
well no no but in all seriousness if the
goal of the team is to win money the
goal of the team is to win contests The
the we want the brand to succeed and the
coaches want the best team possible then
they should have open tryouts and just
bring on the best possible people that
that there are and if the team ends up
being 90 trans women we'll just we'll
win more good right I'm curious as to
when we're going to see an actual big
backlash from women on this actual issue
as it becomes more common because there
aren't that many trans women in these
Sports yet but as we continue to age you
know the the youth I think it's
something like 20 to 30 percent of the
youth nowadays um considers themselves
some form of lgbtq yeah here's an issue
though there's a there's a lot of
problems with early medicalization
question for Trans identified Youth
and this was this was sort of
interesting recently a mom reached out
to me
um and helped me to a talk that was
given by Dr Marcy Bowers at Duke
University who is trans and has
performed some 2000 like trans surgeries
and the trans doctor performing the
trans surgeon right and has performed
these surgeries on young people has also
prescribed the puberty blocking drugs
the loopron as well as the cross-sex
hormones if a child goes on puberty
blockers and then goes directly onto
cross-sex hormones and does not go
through natural puberty they will have
they will never orgasm
they will never have full sexual
function or or the emotional or the
emotional aspect additionally if you're
a little boy and you go on a puberty
blocker and then you start taking
estrogen you will never have enough
genital material to be converted into
the you know wound that is then referred
to as the neo-vagina that will also not
work additionally if you are a young
person and you start taking cross-sex
hormones you're going to have
substantial problems with bone density
yeah blood coagulation all of these
things so the odds that you're going to
be able to play sports are remarkably
small because you're just not going to
have the physical capability to do that
so if a young man go doesn't go through
natal doesn't go through natural puberty
he's not going to be able to play
against Megan Rapinoe anyone who does
that to a child belongs in jail I I
think the one that's happening in how
many states now it's uh what is it
Florida
um I think Iowa maybe Florida there was
Iowa
um is it Oklahoma
Texas I know there's a couple of states
where it's it's illegal they'll they'll
take the kids from the parents right and
then they actually ended up
investigating it was Ken Paxton's office
um and it was actually inspired by Libs
of tick tock uh which lives of tick tock
I talked to her about it and she was
like that was amazing like I actually
helped you know
um but what was interesting is the
Attorney General's office then found
themselves investigating a a parent who
worked at Texas Social Services for uh
medically transitioning their child
I think one of the great lies one of the
big lies in among trans activists
obviously beyond that men can actually
become women and women can actually
become men is that these puberty
blockers have no consequences and that
we have fully studied their unintended
consequences we're right now giving
puberty blockers that were supposed to
be used to treat I forgot what exact
hormonal diseases but we don't fully
understand what these puberty blockers
do when used in the case of gender
dysphoria in children it's not good
there haven't been principles aren't
done and it's not completely reversible
at all
there are consequences yeah that it's
reversible there's like yeah but this is
the argument yeah because also you know
once once a person goes once a child
goes on those those puberty Lupron right
which is uh supposed to address
precocious puberty and then you take the
child off but in the in cases of healthy
children you go on it they put you on it
and then you immediately transition to
cross-ex hormones so you don't don't and
most kids who go on the puberty blockers
do go on to take the cross-sex hormones
because they're already believing it so
it's not a pause button it's an
initiation yeah
yeah
um the thing is you can't exactly tell
when somebody is going on hormone
blockers so it's hard to visibly see how
many people are doing it but what I do
see as somebody who's from New York City
Brooklyn specifically one of the most
trans parts of the city is that double
mastectomy is a relatively common this
isn't something that like you don't see
or hear about from friends or friends or
C you see the people yeah it's
relatively common and I think that too
convincing women that the right move or
whatever you're dealing with
interpersonal women deal with a lot of
issues mentally going through puberty
Etc but to convince them to get double
mastectomies to remove their breasts
again I think is a form is comparable to
modern day lobotomies yeah and not just
women girls I mean children two people
who are underage it happens to the girls
I wanna they're just kids if I may just
one thing they they talk about how um
you know they tell kids if you're not
comfortable in your own body then
perhaps you're trans and I think it's
important for people to realize that uh
it's not really that normal to be
comfortable in your own body like bodies
are super uncomfortable especially
during puberty and especially during
puberty puberty sucks for everybody like
it feels weird and yucky to have your
body change I know personally like I was
18 before I realized that I should wear
a bra and it was my it was my college
roommate who was like you really need to
do this and I was like ew gross I don't
really want to be involved in this oh
you guys are all embarrassed that's
really cute
I mean I never realized
I was like I was I was horrified by
being by like being a grown woman I was
like this is really uncomfortable for a
minute it's called the Bro
right right isn't that uh didn't Kramer
do that on Seinfeld no it was George's
dad that's right no he got he wanted the
manzier the man's ear but he had teamed
up with uh remember one of the Bros
that's right yeah he's like no and they
were arguing about it oh
the bro so let's throw it back to
eugenics in the early 1900s
when we had uh Matt bender on the on the
show I like that segue well it's because
it's the idea that progressives aren't
always right they think they are they
think they always win but that's not
true Sheamus made a good point he said
every you said every instance in U.S
history where someone has tried to to
deny personhood to another group of
people they've always lost something
like that right yeah no group of people
who has ever made the distinction
between human and person and said it's
technically a human but not a person has
ever been on the right side of history
when we examine the situation later so
you look back at Eugenics and we've
we've done away with that it's like a
bad idea nobody likes that yet the you
know tenants of it still exist like uh
when we had Matt bender on the show he
was saying he was he kept saying over
and over again if a baby was born with
deformative abnormality you wouldn't be
in favor of of you know ending its life
and I'm like no and he was like shocked
by that and I'm like I'm not into
Eugenics right like if if a human being
is born different we want it to try and
live if you're what an ableist view that
is and it's crazy disabled here's the
issue genetic diversity is important to
the health of any species this is basic
science it's it's observable if we start
saying these traits are undesirable
where does it end and I'm not going to
oh slippery slope no no quite literally
you have parents being like oh he's got
a heart issue perhaps they're going to
look at the DNA and they're going to say
when he's in his 30s he may experience
this so let's try again okay and then
like you're gonna move the needle more
and more until at what point are you
arguing that it's just designer babies
and at what point do you do you end up
with a disease that primarily affects
people with the specific Gene you know
or or specific cell receptor and then
all of a sudden it's like we didn't
realize that homogenizing the gene pool
was going to result in in population
collapse but here we are so I'm just
like you don't do that awesome well Tim
I mean the left is actually uh disproven
the slippery slope they showed us it's
actually just a cliff I mean you you go
right over instantly
whatever disabilities I'm trying to look
up the exact Source because I remember
this in the past but what I'm reading
right now from the Atlantic is that in
Denmark they actually do tests to see if
the child does have Down syndrome
according to what I'm reading it says
nearly all expecting mothers choose to
take the test of those who get a Down
syndrome diagnosis more than 95 choose
to abort so this isn't just some fantasy
they've eliminated it you know a
scenario that we're talking about this
is actually yeah the thing too is like
you get to decide right like they have
all of these uh because I was older when
I had my son I was like 35 when I was
pregnant and there's all these tests
that they can give you uh that give you
like you know if he's gonna have
whatever there's something about X's I
don't really know but there were a ton
of them and they were like oh you need
to take this and this and this and I was
like why and they were like you know
because it'll tell you if your child has
a deformity and I was like I'm I'm good
I don't care I don't need any of that I
think there is an argument that will be
made about I'm not saying abort children
who have Down syndrome but there is some
version of equality of Life argument but
I do think the argument starts to become
is where do you draw the line to to
where you abort a child I'm not saying
it's okay or not okay for Down syndrome
but you know if we keep moving the
needle or the line it's like well if
your kid has diabetes you know do we
potentially want to abort him because
what if they're short yeah yeah what if
they're short what if they're going to
have male pattern baldness
the end of so many great and very
important people that's right right when
all the parents would have to do is
bestow a beanie upon them exactly so uh
I gotta say I like a beanie Lydia pull
up the story where it talks about
um what is this um Prater Willy syndrome
and it says Studies have found its
positive results are incorrect more than
90 of the time yeah yes I read about
this I think we wrote about this a while
back and it is absolutely insane because
the the genetic testing is not always
correct you want to talk about the death
penalty being wrong what 25 of the time
I want to talk about this test and why
people I'm against all of it I'm against
abortion I'm against the death penalty
I'm against youth in Asia against all of
it this is an important Point like when
we're talking about the death penalty
there's an argument to be made all right
well like 75 of time of the time or
whatever that person's guilty whether
you agree with the death penalty or not
if the number is 25 but whether a child
has Down syndrome or not they're
innocent sin it's wrong to kill them so
when people are horrified because they
go oh my gosh all these children died
who didn't even have the disease that I
think it's okay to kill people with
they're getting it backwards you just
should not kill unborn children yeah
when we were talking with Matt he it was
just it man it was kind of crazy
when he was like you said you would
stand with those who wanted to ban
abortion and I was like I said if my
option was you who wants to legalize
elective abortion at nine months or
standing with the people who had been it
I will stand with the people who will
ban it that's how yeah because that
reduces the amount of death yes but he
didn't understand and he was like you
you just want to ban abortion it's like
no but that's what they're told that's
what they tell themselves they have to
say Tim it has to be for a lot of the
way some people view you it has to be
that black and white that's why you have
to be right wing in that dude's eyes
it's so good you know but it was funny
because it was like two it was like a
progressive and a liberal argument over
abortion and the people who are watching
who are conservative are like these
people are far left everybody's insane I
know right like I'm like I'm I'm
pro-choice and he was like I I asked him
and he said that he thought the woman
can choose to abort the baby at nine
months and I'm like that's not you
Deliverance like the people in the
middle always also get called the
opposite of whatever side so for example
like if you're a 14 weaker pro-lifers
are calling you pro-choice but
pro-choicers are calling a 14-weeker
relatively pro-life right wing 100 yeah
like if you're not up until nine months
then you're essentially pro-life look at
the conversation we had with Matt yeah I
mean but I think like Pro pro-life and
pro-choice is a dichotomy right like
you're either in favor of legal abortion
or against it I realize that there are
some people who are in favor of it at
different stages or against at a
different stage but like ultimately it's
that it's a it's a binary like you're
either okay with abortion or you're not
that's why at timcast.com we say
pro-abortion or anti-abortion yeah
because pro-choice and pro-life are just
stupid buzzwords it's right like like he
Matt says he's pro-choice but not for
men so it's like what do you mean he's
not pro-choice for men women have the
right to make a financial decision to
kill a baby but a man doesn't have a
right to choose to abandon the baby so
if a woman is pregnant and she says I
can't afford this she can termit the
pregnancy it's her body it's her choice
the man could also be broke but he can't
say I would like to be you know removed
from financial responsibility and choose
not to have a child so basically he's
infantilizing women
oh yeah of course I mean that's
typically what the left does they say
that women aren't responsible for their
choices you're not responsible for
having sex with somebody if you had too
much to drink that's on the man even if
the man had just as much
there was a poster went up a school that
went viral several years ago where it
was like have you both had too much to
drink while you're raping her that's
right it's like we were both drunk
you're both trashed bro like especially
I think in Illinois but I think that's
infantilizing in Illinois the statute is
that rape is specifically male on female
and women can't rape like I don't think
there's there's no law for it
can can I mean I guess women can rape
it's hard to imagine no it it happens I
mean there was a story of that guy in
the store where the woman force fed him
Viagra or something oh my goodness yeah
I will say generally it is harder for a
woman to rape a man but it definitely
does happen especially assault but yeah
guys you are just you're oversimplifying
this a guy can be sexually attracted to
a woman and have a girlfriend and be
like I can't do this and then she can
still coerce him or force him she can
lean in his ear and say I'll accuse you
of doing something I'll claim you hit me
she can Spike his drink there's a whole
bunch of stuff there's also been there's
also been I think substantial number of
cases where a female teacher has raped a
male student right you know like if a
male student is 15 you don't have a ton
of control over your whole situation and
your teacher is you know 28 or 30 or
whatever I I think that I think the
Revelation happened I was just reading
an article about that today I think the
the real uh Epiphany for all of us here
is that women are obviously the real
perpetrators the whole time wow there
you go I knew that all along or perhaps
perhaps equality means that everyone is
responsible for their own decisions
and the outcomes and consequences of
those decisions when you talk to him
maybe I read too much Camille Paglia I
don't know when you talk to a
progressive about abortion they say well
the man made his choice he could have
chosen not to have sex and it's like but
not the woman I've heard I've heard
someone say that before
I I once heard someone say that you can
choose not to have sex in order to not
get pregnant like this is they just I've
said this before at some point left
Wingers just end up making right wing
arguments but in really inconsistent
ways right that's what was confusing to
me I was like I don't understand what
your position is like what are you
opposed to and what do you support and
it's just you get these these empty
buzzwords you know it's her decision
it's her choice no matter how many times
me and Sheamus were basically talking
about the baby's body what if the babies
are girls the Babe is it her choice
Matt's answer was it's the woman's
choice and it's like the baby is alive
and being born it's the woman's Choice
like but he's like it's her body it's
like but what about the baby's body it's
like it just right over the head
not I there's no argument you can't
argue with someone doesn't understand
what you're talking about you know makes
it hard yeah
[Laughter]
well I thought I think we we did have a
very productive conversation with Jamie
yesterday and one point he made and
again like I I mean I very much enjoyed
it and by the way I'll say this and we
talked we did it we appreciated you know
Matt coming on and in being willing to
have a conversation with us and you know
I mentioned it was mostly with Tim there
was a couple moments I felt a need to
interject I didn't want it to be on two
two on one there were a few times I was
like all right I have to jump in here
because this is like blatantly correct I
need to say something but what I really
appreciated about Jamie is he clearly
disagreed with me on the pro-life issue
but I felt as if his questions were very
much in good faith and he was sort of
curious about the perspective and he
said something which was we're not
really going to get anywhere with the
dialogue if people like don't have faith
that they can reason with the person
they're talking to and they don't have
some basic empathy and understanding for
the other position
people like you by the way I just want
to say empathy for it doesn't mean it's
a good position and I agree with it like
I think I think it's completely
abhorrent to uh believe in abortion but
also at the same time like I think a lot
of people believe in it because they
just don't understand the issue that
well how can you have a a coherent
political discussion with people who
believe jussie Smollett
um
you can't
yeah that makes it tough like Taylor
Lorenz can write every article in the
world and people just like they stare at
it with drool coming out of their mouths
and it's like maybe this person can't
understand arguments it's so funny that
you just mentioned Jesse smell like
because I just pulled up a
post-millennial article saying flashback
Dr Oz pushed Jesse Smith yeah is that
true yeah
at least our public statements didn't we
we'll see if Dr Oz ends up coming on top
of it Dr Oz also uh was like pro-trans
trans and kids and was pro-abortion like
10 minutes ago we couldn't get Sean
Parnell I know right man have they
called it for uh who's gonna win that it
doesn't matter McCormick versus off I
don't think they called it yet but I
wanted to mention something about Dr Oz
I covered the Pennsylvania rally I was
asking people is Dr Oz America first
most people said no one person that I
spoke to said Dr Oz is the kind of guy
who's supported by like Oprah Winfrey
and like that's why he doesn't like him
and then I responded to him you know
like Trump also supports him and Oprah
originally supported Trump too like I'm
old enough to remember when Oprah
Winfrey supported Trump's original
initially when Trump started running
wasn't Hannity like the the Trump
Whisperer for Oz it was so like it was
so weird to so many people why Oz got
that endorsement it's interesting we're
seeing like this celebrification I don't
know if we're seeing it more I'm just
paying more attention but it's there was
Trump originally there's Dr Oz there's
also I forgot the Superstar football
player college football player in
Georgia who's running for Senate so I
don't remember
um he has the gay son who's a
conservative activist too Walker Walker
Herschel Herschel Walker yeah okay he's
running for Senate I believe too in
Georgia so it's interesting that we're
seeing the celebrification more
celebrities
um throwing their hands
we saw that with Ronald Reagan I mean he
was famous Hollywood actor
all right and you can't if you haven't
already
then Jake button would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you do like it
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have that members segment
coming up at 11 p.m tonight and um what
am I missing oh yeah get your super jets
and we're gonna read some super chats
right now
all right gertius Maximus says project
Veritas presents to catch a redditor
actually hilarious why don't you take a
lean over there
El Guapo says good to see Libby back on
timcast she is such a breath of fresh
air she is so intelligent well spoken
and absolutely beautiful oh my goodness
wow I agree I agree with that guy oh you
guys rylo says ending disinfo board is
evidence they put the cart before the
horse government can only restrict
government speech so how the F could
they run midterm Spygate scandals the
board tasked with stopping disinfo that
is funny they they shut it down because
they realize their only ability was to
call their own lies they're like wait a
minute it's gonna stop us from lying
they were like way too busy fact
checking Joe Biden
they fact checked Joe Biden and they're
like wait a minute the only thing we're
allowed to say is that Joe Biden lied
wait
wait Andrew Irvin says postmanuel is
reporting that 76 brand gas stations are
preparing for 10 a gallon gas and that
gas stations in the Tri-Cities are
running out of gas yeah that's a Katie
Davis courts reporting yeah yeah so I
think we said
um
yeah
maybe we'll talk about an Aftershock
yeah
lunderwear says do a project Veritas
skit like Mission Impossible dossiers on
Twitter that self-destruct and 3D
printed masks for O'Keefe oh yeah
true hello says so you think suspended
his code word for slipping with a black
budget program outside of the purview of
public Congressional hearings that was a
joke that when they're like we're
suspending the program and then all the
journalists write it down say all right
they leave they turn around and the
General's like your budget's being
increased
the other thing too is uh there was
supposed to be a hearing a senate
hearing and it was canceled
oh wow oh yeah the disinformation
governance Board hearing was canceled
because of all of the uh disinformation
surrounding the disinformation
governance board interesting yeah
Amber birds as I can't ignore the
timeline of the disinformation board
shutting down as Bezos says Biden needs
to be fact-checked by the disinformation
board yup yeah that was funny too I I
think they realize what that meant I
think that people would there you've got
a government agency there's going to be
lawsuits and then they're going to be
forced to be like yeah Joe Biden lied
about this lied about this lied about
this and so did Nina jankowitz and so
did jensaki they all lied I think it's
funny that um about the same things over
and over again we joke that the
Department of Defense is actually the
department of offense thanks but then
with the disinformation board it's like
why would we assume they're stopping
disinformation you know if you go to an
ice cream shop are you assuming the guy
who's there is trying to stop people
from getting ice cream or she's trying
to give the ice cream out
so what are they going to do yeah good
point
Andrew Petra says if you haven't watched
the Army's new recruiting video for its
psychological operations career field
you need to really weird and creepy
stuff ooh someone pulled that up let's
say you have to have two moms is this no
that was the Navy right no that was the
Army oh that was the Army yeah that was
the army so well but a lot of people had
to be neuro
neurodivergent so the Army had the ad
about two moms and you know we all talk
about it and Russia started shaking in
their boots and so did China some people
told me that the Army is very
administrative so that's what they were
targeting you know people to work and
file paperwork uh the ad for the Marines
was a guy who was in this in a swamp
with that rifle like you know going
through the trees or whatever
all right let's grab some more
seriously JK says last night's James
O'Keefe undercover running gag was quite
possibly the funniest string of jokes
and ideas I've seen in a long time
thanks guys and we're gonna do it we've
got we came up with a really funny one
afterwards that was um Jaime being
scared of getting canceled we can't we
can't spoil the whole thing should spoil
it no no no we're gonna make it they
gotta see it yeah the ending was
brilliant it was a really good one yeah
all right I won't spoil it I won't spoil
it good stuff all right Thomas just says
yeah to men crew all right very cool
Cole Kirkman says I'm sorry Kirk Kirkham
Tim I just traveled from Houston to
Altoona I'm a traveling tower climber
I'm up here for work I'd love to meet up
with someone about possibilities on
joining the team
I don't know what we have right now
especially for a tower climber good sir
uh we're we're looking for uh for
journalists that's so hard to find
writers specifically people who write
difficult everybody's getting poached up
and whatever yeah it's hard to find
writers all right there are a lot of um
there are a lot of super chats directed
at Libby
weird uh they're saying that Libya is a
good mother oh my god well just I knew I
shouldn't have worn this dress
just leave it there
I even asked Lydia before we went on I
was like I don't know about this dress
yo they're all just saying you're you're
a great mother yeah that's very very
kind yeah JH says I'm late to the party
on this one but everyone needs to watch
the creepy lawn and Prime video very
interesting documentary from 2018 on
Election manipulation via big Tech was
that the Democrat one
but remember the Democrats put together
something they were like really
concerned about voter manipulation
through voting machines back in 2018. oh
that sounds right yeah something like
that yeah right
okay
Smedley Butler III says inflation is an
increase of the currency Supply
devaluing the currency's purchasing
power
which raises prices the one and only
culprit behind this is a printing
machine and its family owners
oh man the chat is going off
what is everyone saying they're just
saying good mother Libby oh my God
that's very complimentary
there's a lot of super chats
thanks Libby oh my God some of these
super jets are inappropriate some of
them aren't come on chat get it together
if you guys made Libby put on a shirt uh
um so we got some big super jets I'm not
going to read that oh my it's my own
it's my own fault for buying a new dress
I'm thinking I should wear it in public
Michael tough says Sheamus please shame
everyone in the chat yeah let's get on
it for shame for shame here's one
stronger says Libya is looking very
pretty tonight Sheamus is okay
I'm glad someone thought I looked nice
it's great I like the purple shirt thank
you very much you know I need to do
laundry the color is amazing Matthew
reckham says Kamala is an Android that
runs on a predictive text AI changed my
mind I know it's really funny did you
ever did you ever do one of those tweets
where you just press the middle
predictive text and then just like put
it out there that's what's you read that
you're like that does sound like a combo
of speech she's did you see her thing
her thing about working together no it
wasn't she no okay I'm gonna find it you
can keep going by the way I find it um
there was a a and I want to mention
about Democrats there was a poll from
The Economist slash it was you Pub I'm
sorry a Hugo poll and The Economist that
said and this was in 2016 that around 50
of Democrats agreed that Russia tampered
with vote tallies in order to get Donald
Trump elected president when you
mentioned voting yeah yeah when you
mentioned uh hacked voting machines I
wanted to bring that up there say one
more time so so it's a yougov poll that
said people believe 50 of Democrats
believed in 2016 that voting machines
were actually hacked or that Russia
tampered with tallies in order to get
Trump elected there was a story I think
it was Newsweek that half the country
believes half of the population of the
country believes the country is being
run by a secret organization they don't
know like they don't know who it is
yeah not surprising but I think the
scarier things that have people half the
people don't think that's true
no because I you know I think when you
read that your assumption is they
believe in the Illuminati when in
reality they're like oh there's probably
like big pharmaceutical big lobbyists
who are doing things we don't know about
and that's actually the reasonable
position but it's also what literally
everyone argues right because the right
will argue things about like there being
a deep state or Corporate America having
too much control the left will argue
similar things about Corporate America I
used to argue uh similar things about
the Deep state and they'll also say
things like well this x y z is a threat
to our democracy the people aren't
actually in control here so I don't know
why that's considered like an insane
conspiracy theory it's pretty mainstream
to not think the government's yeah truly
being uh run fairly we got a good one
here uh John Harrell says BlackRock
neurotech is making their own brain
implant maybe musk is making his as an
alternative to theirs look up the brain
initiative so when you have two
billionaires or a massive multinational
corporation and a billionaire both
looking saying implant my thing into
your brain I'm the good guy what you're
supposed to do is ask the other one ask
uh uh the other one what the other would
say and then do the opposite
um
do you guys know the riddle about
there's two brothers and one always lies
yeah it's like the doors right right you
asked the other one yeah yeah and then
do what the other one tells you to do
but I have the I have the Kamala thing
if you want if you want to see it oh
yeah what is it
right now she said uh we will work
together and continue to work together
to address these issues to tackle these
challenges and to work together as we
continue to work operating from the new
Norms rules and agreements that we will
convene to work together on oh my gosh
oh I said that
is what she said it's like when it gets
stuck in a loop and it keeps giving the
same word over and over again yeah
that's happened to me before yeah yeah
like but she said it out loud I mean if
someone like productive depressing
predictive text and kamala's brain no
you don't understand she's reading a
teleprompter or the person writing the
telepromic it has a predictive text
they're using TV I don't know what's
going on with that but there's like she
actually she actually said that
everything she says makes no sense at
all and the fact like the only thing
that is keeping people from trying to
get Biden out of office is knowing that
we would get her instead I know right
you'll get like a productive predictive
text Loop where you'll write I went to
the movies and what'll come up it'll say
and and you'll hit it and then I went to
the movies and then I went to the movies
and then that's a Kamala Harris Beach
that's how she writes her speeches she's
like hi everybody so I went to my
family's house and then I went to the
movies and then I went to the movies and
then I went to the movies and at the
movies I watched the movies yeah I
watched a movie at the film there was a
screen there was a big screen and there
was a small chair and we sat in a small
chair and watched the big screen
here have you seen separate chairs have
you seen the Family Guy where Lois
Griffin is doing the political debate oh
my gosh no and they're like how would
you deal with the growing financial
crisis and she goes 911 and they go
that's typing and then you know they
asked her another question she goes nine
that's right 11.
they're all screaming
that's maybe maybe she knows something
we don't know
maybe or what if maybe she knows 9 11.
what if it's like half the country's
been taken over by robots and the robots
are speaking clearly to each other and
we are laughing at them thinking we're
so smart and they're taking it's not
smart enough what was that mean you know
that put on the glasses put on the
glasses man they live yeah yeah they're
all James O'Keefe yeah
didn't someone chat that in last night
yeah yeah yeah doing a spoof where it's
a guy he puts his glasses on then he can
see all the James James everywhere
I just I don't know if it's a good or
bad thing that people are gonna like if
every person at every tech company now
thinks they could be getting hit by
James O'Keefe imagine the relationship
problems they're gonna have there's
gonna be an engineer at YouTube who
meets like this amazing woman and
they're gonna have all the same
interests and he's gonna be like it's
James
everyone should have background checks
on every for every yeah for every date
that they have but seriously though
imagine that like imagine in real life a
guy you know meets this beautiful woman
organically and he just gets terrified
and they stop answering the phone and
then she calls one day and she's like
you stopped answering the phone he's
like
like hangs up and she's like that was
weird well or maybe these people when
they go out on dates should not be
trying to impress their prospective
mates yes
let me tell you about corporate
malfeasance I mean stop breaking your
NDA just because you're trying to get
laid like come on it's insane also but
like the things they are spilling aren't
even things that would impress a date
like I only work four hours a quarter
what you're telling her you're lazy why
would you say that on a first date
some of the questions are a little bit
obvious too like when they keep probing
like I think there was one person who
she was like hey what do you think of
project Veritas by the way and this guy
was just completely clueless can I get
that in writing yeah yeah no like the
funniest part when the guy said Veritas
yes exactly the project Veritas employee
goes he gives them info about the
um the person being set up gives them
info about project Veritas that's on
their phone they're reading a corporate
email and the the project Veritas
Reporter Goes project
Veritas how obvious how obvious are you
gonna make it like this is crazy
remember when Homer tried getting Mr
Burns mail and he's like hello my name
is Mr Burns okay Mr Burns your first
name I don't know that's what it was
like I will say this about the Veritas
videos though they do leave me wanting a
little I know they heavily edit a lot of
their dates but I want to see the full
dates of these guys
I want to see the very pretty project
Veritas girl that they definitely hired
with the creepy well I'm assuming they
can only do one gig no because they have
to do more than one gig no I'd be
together they just don't release the
footage of the but then doesn't the guy
know yes but the girl yeah but not
before the guy's looking at her face
yeah but he's gonna try to reverse out
her the guy's not looking at her face
the girls will do multiple stings and
then they release the footage yeah let's
read some more we got bogdanov says Tim
what happened to your members only
comment section on your website why
can't we comment any more on your videos
we will reveal more information in due
time we have to uh do some
infrastructure work for for comments so
we've got announcement coming I can't
say too much but we've when we switched
over to rumble a lot of things had to
change we've got to build stuff uh
that's the easiest way to put it but
we're going to be implementing a bunch
of infrastructure infrastructure changes
to avoid censor to to become more
resilient against censorship wouldn't it
be funny I was just sick of what you
guys had to say I mean yeah I was tired
of arguing no no we want we we want
comments we're thinking of a bunch of
ways we can do it and uh we'll we'll get
it sorted
okay Joseph says I just put in an offer
on for a home on two acres in Minnesota
for 200k the home was built in 73 the
deal is expensive and hard to find near
jobs but uh you know good good going
congratulations
yeah nice yes yeah chickens and goats
and they'll hang out together and
sometimes it's funny the chicken will
ride the goat no way really that happens
do you have goats we don't know okay
yeah we are but there's wait a minute
what's the channel what are you gonna
I what's going to be the project with
the goats riding chickens are we going
to get to see that well it'll probably
just be chicken City but chicken City
with goats oh that's goat Township yeah
well so long as the chickens outnumbers
the goats it's going to stay chicken
City but they get enough goats and then
they're gonna say you already have the
brand I don't know if this is a
replacement Theory chicken City Edition
a replacement Theory the chickens start
getting freaking out the chickens are
like why are our eggs going to the goats
I don't understand why they're like
sending the all the the leg horns get
really worried about it and then you're
gonna have some great cheese too who are
you gonna have come in to make some
cheese the Leghorn joke worked really
well for people who know chickens but
for those that don't they're all white
chickens okay yeah so yeah that makes
sense and then you have we have like the
Red Island Reds or like you know brown
and white so let's read some more Super
chats
Alexander Herald says first SC ever kill
someone in self-defense you have to
prove self-defense so burden of proof
for abortion health and rape would
require investigation similar to
self-defense thoughts four-year fan
that's uh that's actually interesting if
if you were going to create an exemption
for abortion in the case of rape there
would have to be an investigation and
they would have to be able to like prove
it I guess but the left would never
stand for that I mean firstly they
wouldn't want to limit the number of
abortions ever but then I think their
argument would be like no you never
investigate into it because that would
allow them a loophole for basically
anyone to still be able to get an
abortion so long as they said they were
I think some of the most successful
movements in the country are always
trying to you know they try to morph and
live up to the ideals of the
Constitution so I think you know the
civil rights movement did this where
they they were arguing that all men the
Declaration of Independence said that
all men are created equal bestowed with
unalienable rights by their creator so
like you know I think a pro-lifers would
behoove them to make a similar type of
argument what do you mean that like
babies have certain unalienable rights
yeah and we do live up to the values
that are set in our Constitution and
then if we want to change that well we
need amendments to do that so well if
you kill a pregnant woman and you kill
her baby do you get charged
well he killed his wife and baby right
uh she was pregnant if I'm not mistaken
but it depends on the state does it
depend on how far too probably a little
bit yeah all right Bert USA hold on
Scott Peterson was convicted of killing
his pregnant wife and their unborn baby
what state though what state um
Massachusetts
it was either Massachusetts or
California yeah tell me it was before
the heartbeat or after yeah she was
pretty pregnant
yeah there was a case like that in
Massachusetts too
where the guy said that it was a black
guy who came and like carjacked them and
killed his wife so it was on top of
everything else it was like super racist
all right well while Sheamus figures it
out we got Bert USA floorbo says new
case of monkey pox spotted in
Massachusetts the dude got it when in
Canada a little too close to the
Abominable Snowman if you ask me
conspiracy I think not
monkey box what if there's a monkey box
pandemic what is monkeypox it's a
disease you get Sam says Innovation
competence is like other traits it
operates on a bell curve while
percentage stays the same real numbers
change in the far ends push out as
numbers increase so The Highest
Potential ability increases with larger
population for example the top one
percent in 100 versus 100k
that's a really really good point
when you have hundreds of millions of
people the bell curve will get wider
because you have a higher chance of
anomaly
up so actually it's interesting when I
think about it if a if there's a one in
a million athlete but you only have 100
people you're not going to see that that
amazing athlete if a million people
you'll have one at the far end so the
bell curve actually will become wider
Ty Johnson says people want to be
younger today because they were trapped
inside afraid of the outside as children
due to Tech and the parents wanting
safety over childhood
is that what was what it was don't know
uh the Peterson case was in California
was it wow so in a one one of them isn't
California like very pro-abortion
they're so pro-abortion that they don't
even track how many abortions are
performed in the state and it's
Schrodinger's
child where it only counts if you wanted
to yeah when it's not advantageous it
just doesn't I was looking at this
recently and there are a number of
states that don't um report or record or
keep data on how many uh on the like
racial breakdown of abortions so I'm
pro-choice but one of the most
eye-opening statistics that I heard that
was for many years in New York City that
were more black children aborted than
with birth and it just seems it sounds
so outrageous exactly it sounds that
outrageous where you're just like wait a
minute I don't know if it was every year
but it was for some of the years and to
even have gotten close is kind of a
crazy thing to conceptually yeah wow
Margaret sanger's dream come true that's
right that's crazy yeah it was it was
actually a lot it was a lot of abortions
performed in New York it was like New
York and Florida were at the top of
abortions yeah yeah all right we got uh
Josh says I hope you guys are planning
on doing another drinking game next time
Biden has a state of the union that show
was one of the one of the best Tim cast
fam you know what we need to do
we need to do uh
it doesn't need to be the state of the
union we should definitely do for any
you know big event or something we got
to bring Jamie back gilstein and Lauren
Southern yes
and then Lauren can have more of the
Pappy in her paper cup but that was that
was hilarious the show with Jamie was
absolutely hilarious and so we'll just
it'll it'll be it'll be two hours of
just laughing Non-Stop and then everyone
will walk out of the hospital from
ruptured guts yeah yeah he was he
brought a really good energy yeah it's
fun fun and Lauren did you know when she
poured the thousand dollar whiskey in
her paper cup and you know drank it a
lot it was very funny very funny we
enjoyed it very much
Tim you promised me you'd never invite
her back oh she'll be back soon Bailey
Ray says IMO Silverman spoke up because
skaters aren't in a bubble within their
sport they grips in skate parks in the
streets most Parks have all the all
walks of life skating will set you free
I agree with this uh there are a lot of
people who skate who are uh conservative
they just won't admit it that's the
problem conservatives
why is so cowardly yeah if everyone just
spoke up and spoke their mind there
wouldn't be any of this cancellation
backlash nonsense that's right yeah I
think the Coalition is more of an
anti-left than conservative yeah the
anti-left and and when I say anti-left
I'm going to talk about two specific
issues it's that men can become women
and women can become um man it's kind of
this gender ideology issue and then it's
also the defund the police stuff those
are sort of one of their two big
um
things on the left a lot about that
lately I haven't heard a lot about the
defund the police yeah well like a year
ago
it's because BLM isn't as popular and to
defund the police pulled horribly and
the Joe Biden Administration as well as
Democrats know that now after trialing
it so they have to run away from it more
but there's still the ideologues in the
party who do believe that well and BLM
turned out to be a whole bunch of
grifters
I'm gonna give a wag of the finger to
Fox News because they are really
misrepresenting the latest Scandal so
they keep saying that Patrice culler's
paid her her baby's father and her
brother nine seven 970k and 840 000. let
me clarify that because I feel that's
very misleading there's an LLC that does
uh an LLC run by her baby's father does
live production and her brother runs a
security company now by all means I
think hiring your friends and family to
do the jobs as a conflict of interest
when you have less money but the idea
that that money was compensation versus
cost that's what happens when Fox News
says she paid her brother it's like no
no no look
if her brother was doing security
because company how many security guards
did she hire how much money did you
really get so maybe what really happened
is she paid her brother 100 Grand which
is still like you know how should a
non-profit be hiring all their friends
and family the live production thing the
one question I had was they spent 150
000 on a live stream and I'm like okay
now we're asking some questions but Fox
is making it seem like she's just giving
the money straight to her brother to
like do whatever he wants with
so he's getting a lot the other thing
too is if she was receiving more than a
hundred thousand dollars they would have
to disclose that in the 990s they did
not because she probably wasn't it
doesn't mean she's not getting paid in
other ways though so she also said that
those 990s were triggering to have to
fill them out right that was funny oh no
people are going to find out yeah right
I have to do accounting all right Rajesh
says my humble said oh she also said
that she was a she was flush with white
guilt money right yeah yeah but I mean
that's there's she's right I think of
course she was that's why I don't think
that's a problem to say that she is
completely accurate all right Rajesh
says my humble submission to the panel
to re-prioritize issues first dying
microbes in soil leading to starvation
in future hashtag save soil second
climate change real or not we need best
practices to preserve life on this
planet millionth priority feminine men
trying to get attention
um I I agree with the um
more responsible
um
practices when it comes to you know
maintaining the environment all that
stuff my attitude is kind of like I
can't stand the green new deal because
AOC was just like equity and social
justice and when I brought that up to
you know Matt he's like that's where it
starts that's the important thing to
deal with the green New Deal is
minorities and I was like what does that
have to do with winds turbines dude I
don't I I want I want energy sources
that you know don't generate carbon like
nuclear power an amazing return on
energy investment energy energy return
on energy invested and no no carbon
emissions we're all happy right no they
don't want that either yeah also I'll
say this we absolutely need to have a
coherent understanding of sex in order
for society to function because the
family is the building block of society
and sex is what creates families and if
we don't have a functioning Society we
can't hope to solve any of the problems
he's pointing out so these issues are
genuinely important quickly Google has
announced that they're very close to
creating an AI with human intelligence
so perhaps we can just build people
quickly on the climate change issue it's
gonna go great I believe in
amphipomorphic climate change that is to
say that the humans are having some
influence on the climate but I also
believe that we are scientific creatures
and our continued understanding again
new discoveries that we will run into is
what's going to help us steer our way
out of this my issue with the green New
Deal is that it doesn't try to solve
reduce carbon emissions I don't think it
tries to do any of that it just tries to
overthrow quote unquote capitalism and
our current system that is the goal of
the green new deal it's not to reduce
emissions it's to try to force our way
to use Renewables that won't work well
in our system and then also like fun
questionable things because again we
paid like billions of dollars for these
solar panels in China that never panned
out now that we're just overlooking
these costs so the issue with the green
New Deal is that it's more about
communism really and socialism because
that's what happens at these events than
actually trying to make a difference for
the environment right now there's like a
a like an island of plastic the size of
Texas or even larger right now like
North in the North Pacific Gardens so if
any like that is not think that I'm
genuinely concerned about I studied
biology I care a lot about the
environment I've never heard anybody
talk about how we're trying to deal with
that and that's something more tangible
than this climate change I will say that
I I was with a theater company for a
while and we worked for a very long time
on an art project that was about ocean
pollution ocean acidification and the
North Pacific garbage dire that's why I
know all about it I do have a solution
though I've thought a lot about this so
hear me out what if we gave free
healthcare to marginalized people
for the environment don't we actually
would make the environment worse because
you'll produce more refuse like more
more medical ways what we really need to
do is we need to pursue more nuclear
energy
the reason Medicare for all won't ever
happen is because the Democrats will
insist to give uh make abortions
included in health care and also insist
that all illegal immigrants also get
health care that's why this issue I
don't think will ever move forward I
know that's a huge conversation I think
it will move forward because they want
to keep uh using it as an issue that
will never move forward well just what
we'll do
geostationary orbital nuclear power
stations that transmit energy wirelessly
down to the surface how can you look
like lightning sounds like something
from the electromagnetic an
electromagnetic I don't even know or
laser or something yeah there you go
boom problem solved I'm with it then
when it melts down it just blows up in
outer space
and they keep uh taking nuclear power
plants offline I got it guys a Dyson
Sphere around the Sun you know it's
probably solved a lot of green New Deal
people and they'll tell me their
anti-nuclear openly no of course they're
anti-nuclear because the Boomers have
convinced everyone that nuclear is going
to kill everyone and it's not well
they're not really there to solve the
problem I think that's exactly correct
I've got one instead of a Dyson's field
we'll put a Tyson sphere around this
yeah is it like no a Tyson sphere like
Neil deGrasse Tyson it just like
pedantically corrects you about things I
thought you meant like Tyson chicken and
then we just get like a lot of chicken
it's like this to the yeah the chicken
really fast we'll just read a couple
more here
ants honey says you can't fool me James
O'Keefe what have you done with Libby
I admit it it's me I'm about to break
out in song we need to have James on at
one point to just have that happen with
like Lauren will be here and then while
we're talking like wait a minute that's
not Lauren Southern and then we'll have
James jump in and say that'll be
brilliant James and a wig like jumps in
poorly just passed as Lord it was James
the whole time there's a funny meme that
uh Sheamus
uh you tweeted and I saw it someone a
wolf's Bane 1104 made it and it's the uh
the the crazy hot axis have you ever
seen that oh yeah yeah where it's like
you know a woman who's like really crazy
and kind of hot you stay away from like
a woman who's like hot not that crazy
you marry and then normally it says not
crazy and totally hot unicorns don't
exist right he changed it says James
O'Keefe correct
all right
let's see Zach snow says I love this
show but I'm hating the chat tonight
Libby loves seeing you on the show but
you're killing the chat section tonight
it's not me you guys why are you blaming
me yeah I haven't even been in the chat
that's right I've been over here correct
in this chair it's been very focused
with King Kong
all right we'll grab uh we'll grab one
more
uh dorktanian says I will run the
nightly Tim cast IRL drinking show
judging which tropes are shots drinks
and flubs it was flip right it was Flip
Flip Flops yeah I made up a word for
woman you should say florbs again that
was really funny that's good yeah who
was it they were like what word should
we use for a woman then
I was like flib yeah yeah flips I like
floors yeah yeah well floorball is
neutral yeah oh I see that's gender
neutral is yeah so my point was that if
someone tells me I have to use their
pronouns I'll say I won't use the
pronouns that um if you're like hey
don't use he he or him use this or that
I'll say I won't use the pronouns you
want but I'll use totally different ones
you don't expect Florida okay Florida
yeah floorboard told me you know
and then it's like it's but it's nice
it's like floor bow it sounds like it
sounds like a marshmallow it's actually
it's kind of fun to say right which I
think should count with for words it was
meant to be like the bean bag of words
right so it's soft yeah and you're okay
it actually they don't get to tell me
what it reminds me of like a you
remember flowby remember that floby no
do you remember this is that what it was
called flowby and it was like a vacuum
hair cutting tool yeah oh yeah well it
reminds me of if you have not already
would you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're going to record a
members only show and probably talk
about terrifying things and it's not
family friendly but become a member help
support our work you can follow the show
at timcastirl on Instagram or wherever
else you can follow me personally on
Twitter and Instagram at timcast Libby
did you want to shout anything out yeah
so I'm at the post-millennial you can
find us at thepostmillennial.com and you
can find me on Twitter at Libby Evans
I'm Seamus Coughlin I create cartoons I
had a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes if you guys want to go check that
out we're going to be releasing a
cartoon tomorrow about uh Roe v Wade I
think you guys are going to enjoy it
also we're launching a website on May
30th go to freedomtunes.com put your
email in there you'll be notified when
we launch and you'll be able to
subscribe to our subscription service
where you'll get extra cartoons and
behind the scenes content
hey everyone thanks for watching I'm a
lot I'm sure you could find me on all
social media and I'm sure my other stuff
will be plugged in the description uh
thanks for tuning in
and I'm also here in the corner thank
you guys all very much for tuning in I
just wrote another article for my sub
stack today I was talking about Jordan
Peterson quitting Twitter and a blaze of
glory it's really delightful I brought
up a few different points I don't think
we mentioned on the show last night the
show is such a good place to think about
new things that's why I appreciate it
anyway you guys can also follow me on
Twitter and minds.com at Sarah patchlitz
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in just about an hour thanks for hanging
out we'll see you then bye